Die zwei Sprechstunden.
Ich bin ein sehr guter Mensch.
Ich bin ein sehr guter Mensch. Ich bin ein sehr guter Mensch. Ich bin ein sehr guter Mensch. Ich bin ein sehr guter Mensch.
Ich bin ein sehr guter Mensch. Das heißt Chaos Radio, wie ihr möglicherweise auch schon an dieser Musik erkannt habt, die am letzten Donnerstag im Monat hier an dieser Stelle läuft. Chaos Radio bedeutet, dass Leute vom Chaos Computer Club oder befreundete Sympathisanten manchmal auch hier ins Studio kommen und dann über ein Thema erzählen, was die Hackerwelt gerade so umtreibt. Zu Gast sind heute Nibbler und Maha vom Chaos Computer Club. Und es geht heute um ein Thema, das schwierig anzukündigen ist, ohne eine von folgenden Reaktionen hervorzurufen, ob man wieder so, oh nein, ist das schon durch, oder, aber krass, die Schweine. Es geht nämlich heute hier um Fukushima, um das Atomunglück in Japan. Allerdings dann auch wiederum nicht direkt um das Unglück, denn da gibt es ja schon sehr viel Informationen drüber. Und genau das ist auch unser Stichwort. Wir wollen heute mal darüber reden, wie Informationen sich bei diesem Fall in unserer Gesellschaft verbreiten, wie sie verfügbar sind und wie man da rankommt und was man machen kann, weil man sozusagen unzufrieden damit ist, wie man informiert wurde oder wie man informiert wird. Das wollen wir heute klären und es geht so in zwei Richtungen am Anfang. Einerseits ist es ja so, man sitzt da zu Hause vorm Fernseher, wie der Nibbler das gleich nochmal ganz genau erzählen wird. Genau. Und denkt sich dann so, man kann eigentlich nichts machen, man will aber gerne was machen und stellt dann noch ein eigenes Projekt auf die Beine. Nibbler hat das gemacht, der hat etwas auf die Beine gestellt, das sich Geigercroad nennt, werden wir heute mal genauer erklären, was das ist, was da möglicherweise auch Probleme sind, die damit verbunden sind, wenn man so auf die Beine stellt, wie weit das ist, was man dafür noch braucht und solche Sachen. Maha ist hier, weil der eine oder andere kennt ihn oder hat ihn vielleicht schon mal gehört, ist ja ein Neusprechexperte. Neusprech ist ein schönes Wort, das schon ein bisschen älter ist, obwohl es Neusprech heißt. Und da geht es darum, wie man Dinge, die man sagen will oder die man nicht sagen will, so verklausuliert, dass sie wie was ganz Tolles klingen. Das können ja vor allem Politiker sehr gut sagen, sagt man, habe ich gehört. Unter anderem werden wir heute vielleicht lernen, was ein Konjunktiv-Ireales ist. Das ist eine sehr spannende Sache, die Frau Merkel auch angewendet hat angeblich. Aber darüber wird man uns aufklären. Was wir außerdem noch machen wollen, ist tatsächlich darüber reden, was wir darüber wissen. Also ihr seid heute auch aufgerufen, anzurufen. Die Telefonnummer solltet ihr vielleicht kennen. Denn auch, wenn wir die ganze Zeit und seit Wochen bombardiert werden mit Informationen aus allen möglichen Ecken und Enden, würden wir von euch gerne wissen, was wisst ihr eigentlich? Also was glaubt ihr, was da gerade abgeht? Weil so genau kann man es eigentlich gar nicht sagen, weil von uns ja keiner vor Ort war. Und dann, welche Informationsquellen habt ihr euch bedient? Also wenn ihr dazu beitragen wollt, 0331 70 97 110 ist die Nummer. Oder wenn ihr Fragen zu den Dingen habt, die wir heute hier besprechen, heißt es natürlich auch immer, dass ihr aufgerufen seid, hier anzurufen unter 0331 70 97 110. So, so viel dazu. Genau, fangen wir an mit vielleicht ganz kurz. Also wir machen jetzt einen Kurzdurchlauf, einen langen Durchlauf und fangen erstmal bei Nibbler an. Nibbler, Geigercrowd. Was zur Hölle ist das?
Na ja, wenn man so zu Hause, zum Beispiel vor dem Fernseher, ich besitze ja gar keinen Fernseher.
Okay, wir müssen nochmal erklären, dieses Projekt, was Nibbler da auf die Beine gestellt hat, hat ein bisschen Aufmerksamkeit für Aufmerksamkeit gesorgt und da ist bei Heise ein Artikel geschrieben und in diesem Artikel war sehr schön bildhaft beschrieben, wie der Nibbler vor seinem Fernseher sitzt und diese unglaubliche Bilder sieht und sich dann denkt, hey, aber Nibbler hat gar keinen Fernseher. Woher glaubt dir der Journalist, dass du einen Fernseher hast?
Weiß ich nicht, wahrscheinlich von sich auf andere oder wie halt so eine Information einen erreicht. Ich hab das übers Internet erst mitbekommen. Ich weiß, glaube ich, gar nicht mehr, wo. Also bei 9-11 weiß ich definitiv, da war es wie IRC, wie das in Fukushima, das kam eher so langsam. Jedenfalls saß ich dann halt da und hab irgendwie gesehen, hm, das ist gerade nicht so schlimm, was da abgeht. Dachte mir noch, naja gut, die haben das bestimmt im Griff. Ein, zwei Tage später sah das dann halt immer noch so aus, als wäre das alles nicht so im Griff. Und da macht man sich halt die Gedanken, so was kannst du in deiner Situation gegen das tun, was da passiert? Da tun bestimmt viele Leute und muss man halt überlegen, was man so persönlich an Möglichkeiten hat. Und da meine Möglichkeiten auch nur beschränkt sind, ich hab da so ein Netz und ein paar Server, die man zu irgendwas verwenden kann, überlege ich, wo fehlt es eigentlich gerade, dann festgestellt, aktuelle Messwerte aus der Gegend zu bekommen, schwierig, weil zum einen öffentliche Daten zensiert werden oder wie auch immer man das nennen mag, wenn da in den fraglichen Provinzen in Japan steht, an das Survey und für alle anderen Messwerte verfügbar sind und irgendwie seitenüberlastet sind, also da kann man irgendwas tun. Da dachte ich mir, naja, machst du halt mal, bringst du Leute zusammen, die in Japan sitzen und Mess-Equipment haben, sei es jetzt an Unis oder sei es privat, dass ja dann doch, wenn es über einen herkömmlichen Geigerzelle hinausgehen soll, doch ein bisschen aufwendiger. Bringt man die Leute zusammen mit den Leuten, die die Informationen haben wollen und hält das in einer Art und Weise verfügbar, wie man es von so Informationen eigentlich haben möchte.
Also dass jeder hingehen kann und gucken kann dort und dort, es ist gerade so und so radioaktiv.
Genau, also dass man quasi sowas hat wie in Deutschland, die das ODA-Messnetz, was natürlich eher Hightech ist mit einer schicken Karte, wo man eben relativ aktuelles Bild des Messnetzes, was das BFS, also das Institut für Strahlungsmessungen veröffentlicht.
Und das Projekt ist jetzt immer noch nicht ganz fertig, wenn man auf die Webseite guckt. Warum das so ist, erklären wir gleich noch. Kommen jetzt schon mal einen kurzen Einblick dazu, warum Maa heute hier ist. Das hat ja, also sozusagen, wenn man dich öffentlich beobachtet, bei Twitter und auf deinem Blog angefangen, damit, dass du einen Rant geschrieben hast, also einen Ausbruch, könnte man sagen, auf deinem Blog über das Statement, das Frau Merkel unsere Bundeskanzlerin abgegeben hat, relativ zu Anfang der ganzen Geschichte. Welche Laus ist dir da über die Leber gelaufen?
Naja, ich habe das Interview halt gehört und schon gleich, es ging gleich schon los mit dem ersten Satz, wo sie dann sagte, guten Abend, meine Damen und Herren, ich verfolge mit unverändert großem Entsetzen die Ereignisse in Japan. Da habe ich mir gleich schon gedacht, Moment mal, unverändert großes Entsetzen, das ist schon seltsam formuliert. Und dann ging es halt weiter in diesem Stil mit auffälligen Formulierungen. Und das Ganze gipfelte dann eben am Ende in der Fragerunde, wo sie dann gefragt wurde, müssen denn jetzt die Atomkraftwerke, also deren Zeit schon abgelaufen ist, vom Netz? Und dann sagt sie, das wäre die Konsequenz, denn sonst wäre es kein Moratorium. Und damit gebraucht sich den von dir vorhin schon erwähnten Konjunktiv Irealis. Dieser Konjunktiv drückt nämlich genau das aus, was nicht ist oder nicht sein wird. Und damit verrät sie natürlich, dass sie irgendwie nicht so sehr daran denkt, oder dass sie lieber die Dinge nicht vom Netz nimmt. Beziehungsweise sie erklärt es dann ja noch weiter, dass sie zunächst mal mit den Kernkraftbetreibern sprechen will.
Und das war dann quasi der Anfang, weil seitdem hat die Politik sich bemüßigt gefühlt, viele Dinge zu sagen zur Atomkraft. So eine große Änderung ist bei mir zumindest gefühlt jetzt noch nicht eingetreten hier in Deutschland. Was da alles abgegangen ist und was man daraus entnehmen kann und vielleicht auch nicht.
Es kommen halt immer wieder dieselben Floskeln. Es kommt immer wieder der Spruch mit der Tagesordnung. Wir dürfen nicht einfach zur Tagesordnung übergehen, was aber auch ja eigentlich erst mal nichts groß aussagt. Oder vielleicht offenlegt, dass es irgendwie eine Tagesordnung gibt, doch mit Atomkraft weiterzumachen. Und da muss man jetzt einen Moment innehalten, wie die Kanzlerin ja auch in dieser Rede sagte.
Es geht also aber im Großen heute um Informationen. Es geht einerseits um Informationen, die fehlen, und Informationen, die so verschleiert sind, dass man sie kaum wahrnehmen kann. Und wir überprüfen heute mal die beiden Ansätze, also selber was bauen, um die fehlenden Informationen zu beschaffen und mögliche Lösungsansätze, um die Verschleierung der Informationen zu durchbrechen und zu erkennen, was möglicherweise dahinter liegt. Ihr seid wie gesagt auch aufgerufen, anzurufen unter 0331 70 97 110. Maha, aber dir noch die Frage, kannst du dich noch erinnern, wo du das erste Mal davon gehört hast? Von Fukushima?
Fukushima? Ja, bei Twitter. Also ganz sicher bei Twitter.
Ganz sicher bei Twitter?
Also ganz genau, doch. Ich hatte nämlich ein Erdbeben, hatte ich so ein bisschen geguckt und dann tauchte plötzlich, das war Fukushima auf und auch direkt auch schon mit dem Hashtag. Und dann habe ich natürlich sofort geguckt, was ist das denn? Und gleich gesehen Atomkraftwerk, Strahlung.
Helge hat, Helga hat vor dem Unglück überhaupt gar nichts von diesen neuen Medien wie Twitter und Co. gehalten. Das hat sich aber anscheinend jetzt gerade geändert. Hallo und guten Abend Helga.
Ja hallo, schönen guten Abend.
Herzlich willkommen.
Ja, also bei mir ist es so gewesen, ich habe das aus dem Radio erfahren und ich war seit Anfang an eigentlich immer irgendwie so relativ interessiert, aber doch mit Abstand habe ich mir diese ganze Technik beäugt und gedacht, naja, das kann ja alles nur böse böse sein und war ich ein Verfechter davon, von Netzwerken und so weiter, nee, ist nicht mein Ding. Und muss aber sagen, ich habe mich jetzt dementsprechend jetzt erstmals auch angemeldet, Twitter-Account und so weiter, erstmal geguckt, ja wie geht es und was gebe ich hier von mir preis und war aber ganz schnell positiv überrascht über diese Informationsflut, die eben über diesen Kanal plötzlich reingetroffen ist, also gerade in den ersten Tagen oder in der ersten Woche aus unterschiedlichsten Quellen, was man im Radio dann oder im Fernsehen erst ein, zwei Stunden oder viel später erst dann erfahren hatte und das hat mich also ja erstmal positiv überrascht, muss ich ehrlich sagen.
Quasi geflasht vom neuen Medium, findest du das denn als etwas, was unbedingt zuverlässig ist oder bist du dann da auch vorsichtig?
Ich bin generell ein bisschen vorsichtig, was diese Netzwerke betrifft und ja auch selbst bei dem, was ich dann selbst mal so ein bisschen getweetet habe und so weiter, war ich dann immer am überlegen, oh Gott, kann das jetzt einer gegen mich verweiten oder sonst wie. Aber eigentlich ist es Bullshit, eigentlich ist es viel spannender zu gucken, wer hat wo irgendeine Quelle entdeckt und ist das jetzt für mich interessant und verbringe ich jetzt hier sinnlose Stunden damit, irgendwelchen Links hinterher zu rennen oder ja, kann mir das etwas geben oder eben nicht.
Das heißt, du verfolgst das und nützt die neuen Nachrichtenquellen, aber den eigenen Kopf einschalten, nach wie vor eine gute Idee.
Sollte schon so sein, dass man den eigenen Kopf damit einschaltet.
Das finde ich ja auch immer, aber das sehen ja nicht alle Leute so. Wie hast du denn wahrgenommen, was die Politiker hier in Deutschland jetzt die ganze Zeit treiben? Haben die für dich eine klare und deutliche Sprache?
Naja, das ist ein völlig falsches Spiel und was man von dort mitbekommt, also ich denke, da wird erst in den nächsten Jahren irgendwann die wirkliche Wahrheit rüberkommen, was dort abgeht. Ich denke, das können wir uns alle nicht vorstellen, was da passiert. Also selbst die in Anführungszeichen verlässlichen Quellen, also auch wenn man jetzt hier sieht Greenpeace ist vor Ort, macht eigene Messungen und so weiter. Ich denke, da wird es Wochen, Monate oder Jahre dauern, bis die Wahrheit rauskommt.
Du meinst jetzt in Fukushima?
Ja genau, also auch das, was die Politiker sagen, ist ja das Gleiche. Also ich meine, die haben die gleichen Quellen und wissen genauso nur die halbe Wahrheit und werden von dieser Hälfte nur noch mal einen Bruchteil davon rauslassen. Und das ist für mich alles so ein Wischiwaschi.
Aber wie empfindest du das, was hier in Deutschland über die Atomkraft hier gesagt wird?
Ja das war natürlich jetzt erstmal hier für Rheinland-Pfalz und Baden-Württemberg war das erstmal hier Wahlkampfpropaganda schlechthin. Und dieses in Aführungszeichen Moratorium, was ein seltsam blöder Begriff ist, das wollen wir ja alle mal jetzt erstmal noch abwarten, weil dann kann sich ja noch alles ändern oder auch nicht. Aber das ist irgendwie Bullshit, ich meine da geht es um Kohle. Da geht es einfach nur um Kohle für die Atomlobby und die Kohle muss schließen und die Wirtschaft bestimmt uns.
Kannst du, Mara, vielleicht noch kurz erklären, Moratorium, was genau das eigentlich ist? Also weil man hat das so im Gefühl irgendwie was damit gemeint ist, aber was genau meinen die Politiker, wenn sie sagen, wir machen jetzt ein Moratorium?
Habe ich auch nicht gewusst. Habe ich auch erstmal irgendwie so der erste Begriff, was ist denn das jetzt? Erstmal hier googeln müssen und was das heißt.
Wir haben ja mal hier im Studio, vielleicht können wir Ihnen das mal kurz...
Ja, das heißt eigentlich bleiben. Also es wird irgendwas angehalten, was dann bleibt. Also es ist halt eigentlich, man benutzt das normalerweise im juristischen Bereich, wenn irgendwelche Gesetze erstmal ausgesetzt werden sollen, bevor sie dann wieder angewandt werden.
Das heißt aber, in dem Wort steckt schon drinnen, wir machen auf jeden Fall auch wieder weiter.
Ja klar.
Also es ist auch mein Gefühl bei der ganzen Geschichte.
Das heißt du meinst auch sozusagen, okay, jetzt vielleicht noch ein, zwei Landtagswahlen und dann machen wir mal wieder fröhlich weiter mit Atomkraft?
Ja, das wird jetzt alles wieder irgendwie breit gebügelt und spielt dann irgendwie in ein, zwei Monaten keine Rolle mehr, um was es da eigentlich wirklich geht. Da gibt es dann neue Themen und da redet dann keiner drüber.
Eine letzte Frage noch an dich, weil du gut neu bei Twitter bist, weil du das erzählt hast, es gibt immer Leute, die mich fragen, ich verstehe das nicht, ich sage immer, du kannst es nicht verstehen, du musst es selber ausprobieren. Kannst du neuling eine Empfehlung geben, wie man Twitter anfängt?
Ja, ich habe mich einfach ganz silzent mal angemeldet und dann gab es irgendwie drei, vier, ja eben jetzt hier auch zu dem Thema Japan, drei, vier Quellen, wo ich gedacht habe, okay, guckst du mal, was diese Quelle oder eine andere hergibt und im Rückzug bekommt man da eigentlich ja irgendwelche nächsten Quellen und kann sich da anschließen und hier drauf drücken und follow dem, follow dies, follow das. Ich weiß es gar nicht, ich glaube, es sind irgendwie 20 oder 30 inzwischen und lustigerweise gibt es auch welche, die mir folgen, wo ich mir immer denke, ja, ich habe doch eigentlich gar nichts zu sagen. Es gibt irgendwie fünf, sechs Nachrichten, die ich dann retweet, weil ich einfach denke, so das hat mich jetzt irgendwie wirklich interessiert und wer immer das auch liest, der kann es auch jetzt hier mal aus meiner Seite sehen oder als Bestätigung, dass ich das jetzt gut finde und ich weiß auch nicht, ob das irgendwie gut ist, dass man mir jetzt da folgt, also ich weiß nicht.
Das kann man ja aber, das wird er selber ausprobieren, Helga, auf jeden Fall sehr erfrischende Ehrlichkeit. Ich wünsche uns, Politiker wären auch so. Vielen Dank dir und viel Spaß noch.
Ja, schönen Abend noch.
So, wenn ihr noch etwas dazu sagen wollt, zur Information zur Lage in Fukushima und zur Atomkraft in Deutschland und überhaupt 0331 77 97 110 ist die Nummer. Ja, ich würde jetzt gerne noch mal ein bisschen bei den Politikern bleiben. Wieso kann sich dieses Neusprech, von dem man so schnell erzählt hat, wieso erhält sich das eigentlich? Weil im Prinzip immer wenn man so eine Sendung macht oder wenn man mit Leuten spricht, eigentlich glaubt doch keiner mehr, was die sagen, wieso funktioniert Neusprech aber so gut?
Naja, also ich meine, die Politiker sind ja schon irgendwie darauf trainiert, ihre Botschaft drüber zu bringen und eben auch irgendwie möglicherweise was zu verkaufen, also verkaufen natürlich im bildlichen Sinn, also ihre Politik den Leuten schmackhaft zu machen. Und da haben sie sich natürlich schon dran gewöhnt und das geht auch größtenteils wahrscheinlich instinktiv, dass man die eigenen Dinge immer auch schön redet und eben dann schöne Worte gebraucht für das, was man rüberbringen will. Also jetzt auch gerade in diesem Zusammenhang, wo es ja auch relativ schwer ist, über eben dieses, die Gefahren zu sprechen, dann wird eben leicht mal gesagt, ja, wir nennen das jetzt mal Stresstest. Da kann sich keiner was gut drunter vorstellen, aber wir haben einen griffigen Begriff und damit sagen alle Stresstest.
Stresstest hat auch bei den Banken auch schon ganz prima funktioniert, oder? Wir haben auch einen Stresstest irgendwie.
Da hat man es wahrscheinlich, ja, weil man gerade das noch von den Banken kannte. Also man hat es wahrscheinlich nicht. Man gibt ja auch den Stresstest wohl auch in der Informatik und so, aber ich denke, die Politiker haben es von den Banken. Das hat gerade gut geklappt.
Das machen wir einfach normal.
Das machen wir auch mal hier einen Stresstest. Super.
Ich versuche mir das anbildlich vorzustellen, wie so ein Stresstest in so einem AKW irgendwie so.
Ja, da gibt es schon ein Beispiel, das AKW hieß Tschernobyl, da haben sie damals einen Stresstest. Ja, sie hatten es abgeschaltet und sie wollten irgendwelche Tests machen mit Kurzschluss von Strom. Ich weiß nicht mehr genau, steht in der Wikipedia. Und das ging altgehörig schief. Aber das war sozusagen eine Art Stresstest. Aber hier geht es ja gar nicht darum, dass man da irgendwie rumspielt an den AKWs, sondern sie machen ja vor allen Dingen ein Aktenstudium und gucken in den Unterlagen, was können wir da rausholen zur Sicherheit unter besonderen Situationen. Die prüfen ja jetzt nicht, was passiert, wenn man da jetzt was draufschmeißt auf das AKW, wenn man da mal jetzt vielleicht ein kleineres Flugzeug drauf landen lässt oder so. Das macht man ja nicht. Also es ist ja dann kein Stresstest, sondern man guckt, was geben die Unterlagen her. Und deshalb ist das eben auch eigentlich wirklich das falsche Wort an der Stelle.
Um noch mal zu der Frage zu kommen, was mich eigentlich die Frage ist, was du sagst, das trifft immer so schön Nerven, du erklärst das halt sehr schön. Aber im Prinzip ist das auch relativ weit verbreitet. Also man könnte sogar sagen, Atomkraft dafür oder dagegen. Es gibt ja eigentlich, also in meiner Meinung nach, die Mehrheit der Leute sagt, was Politiker sagen, ist eigentlich sowieso Quatsch. Also eigentlich glaubt keiner einem Politiker grundsätzlich Meinung aus. Wieso aber dürfen die dann trotzdem regieren und diesen Neusprech weiter anmelden? Das heißt, warum, oder andersherum gefragt, warum gibt es dann nicht mal jemand, der anfängt die Wahrheit zu sagen und damit dann viel weiterkommt, als die Leute die ganze Zeit faseln?
Naja, doch, das versuchen ja die Leute immer wieder mal. Also Obama hat ja ein bisschen darauf gesetzt, nur, naja, hinterher war es dann wieder anders. Also ich glaube schon, dass man als Politiker Erfolg haben kann, wenn man halt sich so ein bisschen zurückhält beim Schönreden. Und das ist sicherlich vorteilhaft. Aber, wie gesagt, es ist dann meistens so, wenn die Leute es dann geschafft haben, dann setzen sie die alten Rezepte um. Das ist halt das Problem.
Ihr habt ja in dem Neusprechblog, wo du schreibst, mit noch jemand anders, glaube ich.
Ja, mit Kai Biermann, neusprech.org.
Habt ihr ja diverse Begriffe, die jetzt auch immer wieder fallen, in der letzter Zeit auch gehabt. Einer davon ist Schneller Brüter.
Genau.
Was ist daran auszusetzen? Warum ist das Neusprech?
Ein Schneller Brüter hört sich doch super an. Ja, das hört sich super an. Und es hat eigentlich wenig darüber aus, was es ist. Also, das ist eigentlich eine Technik, die hochgradig problematisch ist. So haben wir eben neuen Brennstoff produziert, mit alten Brennstoff. Das ist eben das sogenannte Brüten. Das ist natürlich eine Metapher. Brüten, da denkt man immer so an die Hände, die da auf ihren Eiern sitzen. Ja, die Hasen. So ist dann zumindest, da helfen die da ja aus. Hier wird eben neuer Brennstoff gewonnen. Also Brennstoff ist natürlich auch schon wieder, da sieht man, man kann fast gar nicht über das Thema reden. Das ist derart verseucht von schönen Wörtern. Naja, es wird Plutonium erzeugt und das ist natürlich ganz, ganz gefährlich. Und schnell soll auch nur schön klingen, denn der schnelle Brüter ist gar nicht schnell, sondern der ist attraktiv schnell, bezieht sich nicht auf den Brüter und auch nicht auf den Brutprozess, sondern bezieht sich auf die Elektronen, die halt dort nicht ausgebremst werden. Normalerweise muss man die Elektronen ausbremsen, damit es dann eben auch zur Kernspaltung kommt. Und das will man da ja nicht so stark haben. Man möchte ja vielmehr eben Anreichungen mit Elektronen haben, um halt hier den neuen Brennstoff zu gewinnen. Deshalb werden die nicht ausgebremst. Und weil es eben schnelle Elektronen sind, ist es eben, hoffentlich bin ich ja Geisteswissenschaftler, ich red jetzt nicht alles an. Das sind vielleicht doch Neutronen.
Aber wie auch immer, es wird nicht gebremst. Dafür, für solche Fälle, falls so was passiert, haben wir hier eine ganz einfache Technik eingerichtet, die wir hier im Radio also wirklich lange perfektioniert haben. Jetzt, hallo! 0331 70 97 110 Aber wie müsste denn eine schnelle Brüte eigentlich heißen? Ein genauso langsamer wie alle anderen Radioaktivitätsbrennstoffbeschaffer?
Na ja, es gibt ja schon auch noch andere Ausdrücke. Es gibt ja Brutreaktor, wird ja gesagt, obwohl da auch die Metapher mit dem Brüten noch drin ist. Und ja, man kann natürlich auch irgendwie sagen, dass da eben was dafür Stoffe verwendet werden. Also, dass zum Beispiel Brennstoffe hergestellt werden, oder Plutonium verwendet und so. Dann hört sich das natürlich schon ganz viel gefährlicher an.
Eine Plutonium-Anreicherungsanlage möchte wahrscheinlich keiner in seiner Nachbarschaft haben. Ah, verstehe. Jetzt verstehe ich das Konzept. Sehr schön. Na gut, soweit erstmal. Wir haben jetzt schon einen schnellen Bruder gehabt. Wir haben schon ein bisschen über die Verfaselung von eigentlich ernsthaften Nachrichten in der Politik gesprochen. Wir haben kurz angerissen, was Geigercrowd ist und werden das gleich mal genauer an den Mann bringen. Vorher hören wir einen kleinen Track. Ich rufe ja vor der Sendung immer auf, ihr könnt Creative Commons Musik euch hier wünschen, wenn ihr wollt. Und spielt ihr denn immer nicht, weil wir immer so viel reden. Ich habe jetzt heute dieses eine Lied, möget ihr mir dann verzeihen, von Binaire-Pilot Tear Light heißt es. Und das spielen wir jetzt. Creative Commons Musik könnt ihr auch runterladen. Danach gibt es Fritz Info, Nachrichten, Wetter und Verkehr. Und danach kennen wir ganz ausführlich, was Geigercrowd eigentlich ist, wie es funktioniert und werden uns mit dem schönen Wort Restrisiko beschäftigen. Wie immer das Chaos Radio. Es geht heute um Informationsbeschaffung und Analyse im Zeitalter von Atomunglücken. Man könnte auch sagen verstrahlte Information, Verstrahlter Informationsverkehr. So heißt es ganz richtig. Zu Gast sind heute Nibbler und Maha vom Chaos Computer Club. Nibbler ist da, weil er ein Projekt auf die Beine gestellt hat, wo Leute, ach, ich höre einfach selber.
Ja, saß er halt am, zusammen, zusammen, alleine zu Hause.
Zusammen mit sich selbst.
Vor nicht dem Fernsehen, sondern in dem Fall dann doch Twitter. Ja, so Gedanken, die man sich halt irgendwie vor dem Einschlafen macht. Sowas kann man so irgendwie ausnehmen, was man den Tag über so gehört und gesehen hat. Angefangen hat das ja, als diese Situation in Fukushima immer brenzliger wurde. Am Anfang war ich auch noch der Meinung, naja, gut so AKWs, das ist doch eigentlich halbwegs beherrschte Technik. Bis man sich dann doch mal ein bisschen besser informiert, als man das bisher getan hat. Was ein spannendes Phänomen bei Twitter ist, irgendwie eine Woche sind alle Leute Experten für Doktortitel und die Woche drauf sind es Atomkraftexperten. Dann hab ich mir überlegt, was kann man so gegen tun aus einer individuellen Situation, weil ich jetzt doch eher weniger der Mensch bin, der jetzt mal blind dem Roten Kreuz oder wem auch mal Geld überweist und hofft, dass er dann damit seinen Teil in der Gesellschaft getan hat. Ich hab mir überlegt, was kann man da tun? Wo gibt es ein Problem, was man selbst angehen kann? Und auch im Hinterkopf noch eine Veranstaltung hier in Berlin gehabt, wo mal so ein Hackwochenende stattgefunden hat, wo man sich irgendwelcher humanitären Probleme angenommen hat. Das war Random Hacks of Kindness. Random Hacks of Kindness. Ah, glaube ich. Und da eben, ja, viele, eine Handvoll Teams, die sich da spontan zusammengefunden haben, die irgendwelche Probleme angegangen sind. Und das hat mich schon so ein bisschen beeindruckt, dass man eben wirklich mit einer Handvoll codern, die gerade Lust haben, ein informationstechnisches Problem lösen kann. Also da haben Leute, die, ja, die verschiedensten Dinge.
Wir lassen uns jetzt mal bei Dinge und kommen zu deinem Projekt Geigercloud. Es geht ja darum, dass dir oder mehreren Leuten gefehlt hat, dass die Leute wenig Daten darüber hatten, wo es wie verstrahlt ist. Und das wolltest du mit dem Projekt beheben. Wie genau soll das da funktionieren?
Genau, also das Problem war eben, dass es zum einen keine verlässlichen Daten gab, zum anderen, also unter verlässlich meine ich Daten, die verfügbar sind über eine längere Zeit, also wo man auch vergleichen kann und zum anderen eben Daten, die aus verschiedenen Quellen stammen, sondern halt mal hier jemand mit einem Messgerät, mal hier da jemand mit irgendwelchen Daten und natürlich die offiziellen Daten, die in den interessanten Gebieten mehr als lückenhaft waren. Da dachte ich mir halt, okay, das geht besser. So die Daten, die irgendwie interessant waren, die dann oft wieder rumgingen, da waren die Seiten dann überlastet und das ist ein Problem, dem ich in der Vergangenheit schon durchaus Erfahrungen gemacht hab. Ja, da liegt zum Beispiel der, also in dem Netz, wo jetzt auch Geigercloud liegt, liegt auch der Alternativlos Podcast. Also große Datenmengen, die gerne abgefragt werden, sind wir gewohnt. Und hab dann mal so mehr aus, mal gucken, Twitternachricht rausgeschickt. Irgendwie gibt da irgendwie Ressourcen, die man gerne mit irgendwie einer Seite, wo diese Informationen aggregiert werden, föhnen kann. Hat denn jemand Lust, so was zu bauen? Und da haben sich dann auch die ersten Leute gemeldet, die Interesse hatten. Unter anderem war das gleich mit einer der ersten, Helge Rausch, der bis jetzt auch mit dabei ist und fleißig kodet. Ein Freund von mir aus München hat sich gemeldet, meinte, eine coole Idee, hat da auch im erheblichen Umfang mitgeholfen. Wir haben dann Physikstudenten mit im Team, der sich auch mal mit dem ganzen Hintergrund, weil er so naiv ist, der glaube, man nimmt einen Geigerzähler, schreibt die Werte regelmäßig ab. So einfach ist es halt nicht.
Wie viele Leute sind es insgesamt, die da jetzt mitmachen?
So sechs bis acht im Kernteam.
Und warum ist die Seite eigentlich noch nicht online? Also das war ja damals, als es losging, war ja die Hoffnung, dass es dann gleich bis zum irgendwie also innerhalb von drei oder vier Tagen dann bis zum ersten Wochenende irgendwie an den Start kommt. Das hat sich noch verzögert. Warum?
Ja, es gab da auch schon die ersten Seiten, die ein ähnliches Konzept gemacht haben, aber was da halt mir überhaupt nicht gefallen ist, dass sie sehr viele externe Ressourcen zusammen genommen haben. Also beispielsweise Google Maps Karten, wo dann die bloß mal hier mal da irgendwelche Werte, die von irgendwoher kommen, reingespeist sind. Wir haben da so ein bisschen einen höheren Anspruch gehabt, also zum einen, dass wir die Werte in einer gewissen Weise verifizieren und gucken, was haben die Leute für Equipment. Öffentliche Quellen zusammen aggregieren und eine Karte darstellen, die jetzt nicht irgendwo auf Google Maps, sondern die wirklich einfachen Bild ist, wo man dann auch noch detaillierte Daten bekommt, ohne auf irgendwelche externen Ressourcen angewiesen zu sein, weil gerade wenn man irgendwie mit einem schmalbeinig angebundenen Gerät irgendwo in der Pampa steht und wissen möchte, wie sieht es gerade hier aus, dann hat man halt das Problem, dass im Zweifel ein Formativtelefon aus diese Google Maps Karte eben nicht tut oder vom Format her, einem nicht die Informationen bringt, die man irgendwie möchte. Gerade in einer Situation, wo man ein größeres Airbnb in einem Gebiet hatte, darf man nicht von ausgehen, dass die Leute da mit dem Notebook sich ins WLAN einbuchen und dann halt auf einer Karte rumklicken können.
Gemütlich beim Latte im Café sitzen und irgendwie das WLAN nutzen. Ihr wolltet es also mit anderen Worten ordentlich machen, nehme ich dem. Wie lange wird es denn noch dauern?
Es gibt jetzt demnächst ein Treffen, da muss ich jetzt noch mal gucken, ob wir da schon einen Termin haben, wo wir uns noch mal zusammensetzen. Aber das Datenmodell ist soweit klar. Da haben wir auch, wie gesagt, mit dem einen oder anderen Physiker mal darüber gesprochen, inwieweit das Sinn ergibt, welche Messwerte wir denn haben wollen, was wir für Informationen brauchen, um eine ähnliche Visualisierung, wie es diese Ortsdosisleistungskarte bietet. Zwar können wir nicht überall die Ortsdosisleistung, weil das schon gehobene Lieger, was Equipment angeht, aber dazu soll halt alles so ein bisschen fundiert sein. Ich kann keine genaue Zeit da nennen, weil ich es nicht besprechen möchte.
Wie schwierig ist es in so einem Projekt immer aufzuhalten? Weil man merkt das ja jetzt schon in den Medien. Im Prinzip ist die Lage in Fukushima an den Reaktoren unverändert krass und schlimm.
Aber die Aufmerksamkeit wird weniger.
Genau, man weiß nicht genau, was da passiert. Darüber müssen wir auch nochmal reden. Eine partielle Kernschmelze hat angefangen, so heißt das, glaube ich, was ja irgendwie auch ein schöner Euphemismus ist. Und dazu kommt ja das Nerds auch dazu tendieren, sich für Ideen schnell zu begeistern und dann aber auch wieder der Tatendrang erlischt dann auch schnell. Ist das ein Problem bei dem Projekt jetzt?
Glücklicherweise nicht, also die Leute, die dabei sind, auch jetzt nach dem Heiser-Artikel sind nochmal welche dazugekommen. Die machen das halt in ihrer Freizeit nebenher und ja, für die ist das schon durchaus dann auch was, was in Zukunft an anderer Stelle verwendet werden kann, weil ja, Messwerte zusammen aggregieren, auf einer Karte plotten, ist durchaus was, was mag man jetzt nicht hoffen, aber durchaus auch in der Zukunft für andere Dinge interessant sein kann.
Also die Hoffnung ist natürlich wieder das falsche Wort, aber es wird nicht nur jetzt für Geigercrout gearbeitet, sondern das kann man dann auch später auch für andere Projekte dann quasi finden.
Ja, das Software ist open source, ist verfügbar auf GitHub. Den Link kann man mit der Sendung noch ins Wiki schreiben.
Genau, kann ja irgendjemand mal ins Wiki schreiben, dafür gibt es das ja.
Und ja, das ist natürlich auch Grundlage für andere Leute, da darf man sich gerne dran bedienen.
Wenn jetzt Leute zuhören, die denken so, hey, geile Sache, darf ich auch noch mithelfen? Was sucht ihr noch? Wen sucht ihr noch? Was braucht ihr noch?
Wir haben auf der Seite ein Kontaktformular. Es gibt auch ein Wiki dazu, wiki.geigercoard.net. Das ist weitestgehend selbstorganisierend. Ich stecke da auch nur die Zeit, die ich eben habe, rein und versuche, die Leute zu koordinieren. Aber im Prinzip ist das ein kleines Gruppchen, was sich da inzwischen gebildet hat.
Aber es gibt wahrscheinlich sozusagen Eckdaten, die möglicherweise jetzt nicht alle Leute verstehen, die aber den Leuten die Ahnung davon haben, sagen, was er da macht. Also irgendwie Ruby ist es, glaube ich, in Ruby.
Genau, es ist in Ruby geschrieben, weil sich das ziemlich gut dazu eignet, mal eben so ad hoc ein Projekt durchzuziehen zu deren Mehreren. Und da hätte sicher der ein oder andere Kodamier auch nicht schlecht.
Wer Ruin programmieren kann und will und ein bisschen Zeit ruhig hat, kann sich also gerne melden. Wie ist das mit dem fachlichen Hintergrund? Du hast jetzt schon erzählt, ihr habt irgendwie Physikstudenten am Start, der euch da ein bisschen auf die Wege bräuchte, der da auch noch Unterstützung?
Im Prinzip ist jede Unterstützung gleichermaßen willkommen. Also wer da Lust hat, so sein persönliches Bedürfnis an, ich muss da jetzt was tun, ich möchte da was dagegen tun, stehen möchte, das herzlich willkommen.
Alright, dann letzte Frage noch. Die Seite ist ja direkt auf Japanisch auch gleich am Anfang gewesen. Wie habt ihr denn das hingekriegt so schnell? Du sprichst kein Japanisch so viel, ich war ja...
Ich hab relativ früh einen Kontakt von jemandem aus den USA bekommen, der in Japan aufgewachsen ist und jetzt sein Studium in den USA fortgesetzt hat. Und der hatte eben genau das gleiche Problem, hat gesehen, da ist irgendwie ein Unglück, aber so richtig was dagegen tun, wusste er jetzt auch nicht und hat sich riesig gefreut, dass er zumindest an der Stelle was tun kann, weiterhelfen kann und hat uns angeboten, eben die Seite zu übersetzen. Wir haben das natürlich nochmal durch Google Translate geschickt, weil das weiß man ja immer nicht. Ja, das war ungefähr der Text.
Kauft hier Hilfe, Dinge, die euch helfen, eure, naja, egal. Dann lass er sagen, das war alles echt. Da könntest du sagen, ein zweiter auch nicht schaden, falls du hier mit der Panik spielst. Jetzt ist das Projekt, das ist ja eine coole Idee, er hat das auch an Klang gefunden, dort wo es gebraucht wird, habt ihr von da auch Rückmeldungen bekommen?
Ja, wir haben von einzelnen Japanern, die Zugang zu besserem Mess-Equipment haben und auch von einzelnen Leuten, die zu Hause mit dem Geigercelder sitzen, Info bekommen. Wir würden da gerne irgendwie die Daten, die wir so haben, die stellen wir auch so ins Internet, wenn ihr irgendwie eine Schnittstelle mit uns ausmachen wollt, sprechen wir da gerne drüber und da sind wir eben gerade dabei, das Ganze zu integrieren. Also wir haben jetzt schon ein Datenmodell, wo wir die ganzen Sensorenwerte abbilden können und die ersten Daten uns da schon zusammen sammeln von Leuten, die in Japan sitzen und die sagen, es ist super, dass es eben noch eine andere Quelle gibt, außer denen, die so mehr oder weniger verfügbar sind. Das ist ja eigentlich so ein Open Data Problem. Normalerweise sind das Daten, die man von der Regierung bekommen sollte, wenn da Messinfrastruktur besteht. Und trotz, dass Japan ein hochtechnologisiertes Land ist, ist das schon offenbar schwierig, an diese Rohdaten ranzukommen.
Aber das ist nicht Problem dessen, dass es die nicht gibt. Also ihr geht schon davon aus, die gibt es, die werden noch nicht veröffentlicht.
Es gibt die Daten auf jeden Fall. Ich meine, man muss ja irgendwie sich so eine Information, als Regierungen so eine Informationslage selbst erschließen und das sind eben Daten. Und ich sehe das auch in Deutschland, dass das ein unglaublich schwieriges Thema ist, an so Rohdaten, an so Statistikdaten in einem verwertbaren Format ranzukommen, dass man da von dritter Stelle nochmal irgendwie drüber gehen kann und sagen kann, sind Daten, die man für irgendwie, ja, die man verwendet.
Ja, wir nennen das Open Data, ist ja auch ein wichtiger Aktionsbereich des Clubs, eben Open Data zu machen und eben an Rohdaten ranzukommen und die zur Verfügung zu stellen.
Das ist genau der öffentliche Datennutzenteil von dem Spruch öffentliche Datennutzen.
Genau, so, jetzt habt ihr damit angefangen, jetzt dürft ihr es nochmal ausführlich erklären. Selber schuld.
Ja, naja, Open Data ist halt eine Initiative, die unter anderem natürlich auch vom Club unterstützt wird, also vergleichbar mit Open Source. Bei Open Source geht es ja darum, dass der Quellcode von irgendwelchen Programmen offengelegt wird. Bei Open Data geht es eben darum, dass Verwaltung und Regierung Daten, über die sie verfügen, so zur Verfügung stellen, dass man die eben leicht auch auswerten kann und vor allen Dingen auch die Rohdaten zur Verfügung stellen. Also nicht irgendwas Aufbereitetes, was man irgendwie abgetippt hat, was man dann wieder eingescannt hat, dass man also gar nichts damit anfangen kann, wenn es nur Bilddateien sind, sondern dass man eben wirklich die Rohdaten eben auch im Netz zur Verfügung hat, um eben die Regierung maschinenlesbar zu machen. Das ist eine alte Forderung des Chaos Computer Clubs. Zusammen mit öffentlichen Daten netzen, private Daten schützen, die maschinenlesbare Regierung. Und daran müssen wir arbeiten. Das zeigt jetzt gerade dieses Unglück. Also wir müssen in Deutschland auch dazu kommen, dass wir eben hier wirklich auf Daten der Verwaltung jederzeit im Netz zugreifen können.
Das ist ja auch nicht nur für Daten bei so einem Unfall oder so einem Unglück wichtig, sondern allgemein für Daten auch in der Forschung und so weiter. Das täte es sehr gut, wenn man eben auf bestimmte Daten nicht zugreifen kann, durch Papier abtippen, sondern eben automatisiert. Gerade das ist der Scham von moderner Vernetzung, dass man eben mit zu Daten dann besser arbeiten kann. Und ganz unterschiedliche Datenquellen miteinander kombinieren kann, und dann ganz neue Erkenntnisse, auf die man vielleicht so nicht gekommen wäre, weil man die Daten nicht hat, bekommt.
Ihr wisst ja eigentlich, wie es aussieht, betrefft Sicherheit von Atomkraftwerken in Deutschland. Da gibt es jetzt viele Experten, die haben eine Meinung zu. Gibt es die Dinge, auf Grundlage derer, die argumentieren auch öffentlich? Weiß das einer von euch? Weiß keiner so genau, ist also auf jeden Fall auch wieder ein Fall von...
Jetzt anrufen!
0331 70 97 110 Wenn ihr da genaueres drüber wisst, gerne mal hier anrufen.
Was es auf jeden Fall nicht gibt, ist ein RSS-Feed von den ganzen Störfällen. Das wäre mal interessant. Den Tag über in deutschen AKWs mal so als Rohinformationen wirklich... Ich meine, die müssen das ja melden. Es gibt irgendwie meldepflichtige Störfälle und weniger meldepflichtige Störfälle.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, du meinst die kleinen Dinge sozusagen, die passieren ohne dass wir...
Einfach mal, dass man so das im Überblick hat.
Es gab doch diese eine schöne Szene aus, war das ZDF oder NDR, oder was ist diese eine Dokumentation, wo in Brockdorf eine Lampe anging, die irgendeine Systemgefährdung anzeigte und dann die Leute so, ja, machen wir jetzt.
Ich frage mich, ob der Aktionismus, den sie da geschoben haben, wirklich nur war, weil die Kameras da waren und sie das ansonsten ignorieren, weil sie da so ein bisschen Pläne rausgeholt und ein bisschen missmutig mit dem Finger auf den Plan rumgedeutet haben, dann ist es irgendwann ausgegangen und dann ganz leicht, okay, auf ein paar Tasten gedrückt haben sie auch, also irgendwie so ganz planlos.
Oh mein Gott, falls jemand den Link parat hat, bitte gerne auch ins Wiki zur Sendung posten, wer das noch nicht gesehen hat. Das ist wirklich erstaunlich und ein bisschen furchteinflößend, was da passiert. Wir reden heute im Chaosradio über Informationen und die Art und Weise, wie die uns auch hier in Deutschland präsentiert werden jetzt zum Thema. Wie machen wir denn weiter mit der Atomkraft? Und wir wollen auch eure Meinung darüber wissen. Ihr könnt gerne anrufen 0331 77 97 110 und uns vielleicht auch mal in eurem Stand teilhaben lassen. Das finde ich auch mal spannend, wenn jemand anruft und sagt so, ich weiß jetzt über die Situation folgendes, und zwar aus der und der Quelle. Wer auf jeden Fall angerufen hat, ist der Jonas, der sich über die Widersprüche in der Politik wundert. Hallo und guten Abend. Worüber wunderst du dich denn genau? Und vor allen Dingen, was sind für Widersprüche? Das ist doch alles ganz klar und einfach erklärt.
Ich fühle mich, ich fühle mich zur Zeit von der Politik gezielt desinformiert. Und zwar inwiefern, dass wir, als es um die Atomlaufzeitverlängerung ging, die Regel davon hatten, dass es alternativlos sei, ist ja auch so ein Neusprech, dass es alternativlos sei, dass wir die, dass wir alle, auch die Maroden, also meiner Meinung nach Maroden, wenn es z.B. Greenpeace-Aktivisten schaffen, und Bander zu entrollen und auch das Video, was ihr vorhin angesprochen habt, dass die als Netz bleiben, als Übergangstechnologie, bis zu den regenerativen Energien. Und dass das so sein muss. Und dass wir jetzt die Situation haben, sei es wegen dem Wahlkampf, oder sei es warum auch immer, dass es geschafft wird, sieben Atomkraftwerke abzuschalten, ohne dass Energie aus dem Ausland importiert werden muss und ohne dass Energieeinpusten stattfinden. Und das, obwohl das ja eine zentrale Energiequelle ist, die Atomkraft.
Das ist doch jetzt eine völlig neue Situation.
Ja, und jetzt habe ich mich eigentlich mal gefragt, habe ich jetzt die Möglichkeit, mal zu erfahren, welche Kapazitäten eigentlich zur Verfügung stehen, Energie zu erzeugen? Denn die sieben Atomkraftwerke haben ja nicht wenig Energie erzeugt, und die gehen jetzt vom Netz, ohne dass Energie importiert werden und ohne dass irgendwelche Einbußen sind. Und da habe ich natürlich, ich habe jetzt die Forderung, vom Staat erfahren zu können, welche Kapazitäten stehen wir, also stehen uns eigentlich zur Verfügung, Energie zu erzeugen. Weil es zurzeit einfach nicht möglich ist, zu wissen, ohne wie viel Atomkraft könnten wir eigentlich theoretisch kommen und welche Energie kann erzeugt werden.
So, das ist der Punkt, wo ich jetzt nochmal die Telefonnummer sage, 0331 77 97 110. Wir reden gleich nochmal über die Politiker, weil ich habe darüber schon was gelesen.
Das ist ein klassischer Open Data Fall, also es gibt diese Strombörse, wo man sich die Informationen aus den Pflichtmeldungen anschauen kann, aber alles, was darüber hinausgeht und gerade so kleinere Windanlagen und so weiter sind da nicht so mit drin, weiß man halt nicht.
Naja, also die Energieherstellung findet auch zum Teil statt bei Unternehmen, die zwar Pflichtmeldungen machen müssen, aber durch nie so genau sagen, wie viel sie könnten und so, weil ja auch diese Strombörse, das ist ja auch nochmal was, da wird ja auch damit gespielt. Da wird ja dann, wenn man sagt, aha, der Preis muss jetzt ein bisschen höher gehen, da wird also weniger eingespeist ins Netz, als die Firmen eigentlich einspeisen könnten. Und das wird natürlich dann nicht leicht publik gemacht. Was findet dann mal irgendjemand raus?
Lustige Situation, wo zu viel Energie eingespeist wird und du für die Abnahme von der Energie nochmal Geld bekommst. Das passiert so ein, zwei, drei Mal im Jahr, habe ich das Gefühl, wo man dann so einen Graphen sieht, wo der Strich unter Null geht und man dann halt minus fünf Cent für, also ja, wo zu viel Energie da ist.
Und da stelle ich mir dann auch irgendwie die Frage, warum können so eine zentrale Sache und so eine einfach wichtigen Sachen und Sachen, wo es um Atomkraft geht, das heißt, mit denen wir unsere Umwelt nachhaltig zerstören können, wieso kann das in privater Hand liegen? Und wieso wird das nicht vom Staat gesteuert, wenn ich nicht die Möglichkeit habe, vom Staat diese zentralen Daten wirklich auch als Rohdaten zu erhalten, welche Kapazitäten da offen liegen? Wenn es um Energie geht, die gefährlich sind und die fädlich sein können, da denke ich einfach, dass das in staatlicher Hand gehört.
Meinst du wirklich, das würde was ändern, sozusagen, wie das funktioniert? Weil dann wäre es halt auch eine Behörde. Also die werden jetzt auch sagen, mehr oder weniger so, wenn dieses Video von dem war, so verwaltet irgendwie die Dinge, die es da gibt.
Es muss halt auch der Wille dazu da sein, also die Erkenntnis, dass eben das nicht nur so ein bisschen Markt hin und her, sondern dass davon halt auch die Zukunft unserer Gesellschaft abhängt.
Naja, also dieser Markt ist ja auch ein Pseudomarkt. Ich meine, man kann sich ja schon vorstellen, da gibt es irgendwie viele Leute, die haben ihre Photovoltaik auf dem Dach oder im Garten irgendwie auch noch so eine Bio-Anlage, also irgendwie Erdwärme-Anlage oder sonst was. Und die speisen da was ein. Klar, dann wäre das ein Markt mit so kleinen Mitspielern und dann gibt es halt auch so Markteffekte. Aber was hier ja passiert ist, es gibt Oligopole, also es gibt ganz wenige große Energiekonzerne, RWE, EON, wie sie alle heißen. Also sind es glaube ich vier oder so. Ich brauche wieder den Chat, ich weiß es nicht genau. Und das ist natürlich eigentlich das Schlimmste, was man haben kann. Man hat nicht den Staat und man hat nicht die kleinen Mitspieler, so eine Hand, so etwas dazwischen. Und die dann, also diesen Markt beherrschen, der dann gar kein wirklich freier Markt ist.
Das ist ja dann auch ein Problem, das uns ja im Prinzip auch durch die Medien gesagt wird, dass diese zentrale Erzeugung von Energie nötig ist und tun umgänglich. Und dass diese Alternative durch eine dezentrale Erzeugung von Energie, eben durch Kleinanbieter oder eben auch nur durch die Photovoltaik-Anlage auf dem Dach, dass die in vielen Szenarien in den Medien gar nicht bedacht wird.
Oder auch die Energiespeicherung, weil Windkraftanlagen zum Beispiel erzeugen nicht kontinuierlich Energie. Das war bisher immer das, was ich gelobt habe, dass wir diese AKWs brauchen, weil nur neuerquare Energien das Problem mit der Lastverteilung haben. Aber war das Schweden oder Norwegen? Irgendwann hatte enorm viele Pumpspeicherkraftwerke. Da gab es das Projekt, dass wir den Strom zu denen exportieren, wenn wir ihn gerade nicht brauchen und ihn wieder von uns holen, uns von denen holen, wenn wir den brauchen.
Zum Schluss noch ein Pumptschlecherkraftwerk heißt irgendwie, ich liefere Strom an ein Kraftwerk, das pumpt Wasser irgendwo hoch.
Genau.
Wenn ich den Strom brauche, lässt das Wasser wieder runter und betreibt damit zu.
Genau, damit wird sozusagen der Strom natürlich gespeichert, weil das Wasser dann oben ist und dann wieder neue Strom erzeugen kann, wenn es runterläuft. Das ist eigentlich eine gar nicht so dumme Sache. Es hat allerdings auch wieder viele Nachteile. Man sieht es jetzt, da gibt es eine Diskussion in Baden-Württemberg, dass die einen sagen, wir brauchen mehr Pumptschlecherkraftwerke, und die anderen sagen, aber unsere schönen Schwarzholzthener, die sollen doch jetzt in die Allianz Riese-Gestausees verhandelt werden. Das ist halt auch ein Problem, da gibt es auch noch mal einen Konflikt.
Aber nur noch einmal, um das zu Ende zu führen, diese Nordsee-Leitung, um eben diese Energie zu exportieren und zu importieren, da scheint es unglaubliche Probleme politischer und anderer Natur zu geben, die können es nicht geschaffen werden, dass das eben nicht stattfindet. Sollte man sich mal überlegen, ob man da nicht mal…
Was eigentlich?
Die Lösung liegt auf der Hand.
Inwiefern jetzt?
Na ja, das halt einfach mal tun, mal gucken, wieviel man da durchglätten kann und halt wirklich mit dem ehrlichen Ziel, wir versuchen von der Atomenergie nicht durch garantierte Restlaufzeiten, sondern wirklich best effort, runterzukommen.
Also quasi so schnell, wie es geht. Das ist ja nicht so beliebt, glaube ich, diese Ansage. Thomas meint dann gleich, das ist eigentlich totaler Quatsch, weil in Frankreich werden sowieso Kernkraftwerke gebaut.
Die zwei Sprechstunden.
Heute Chaosradio. Es geht heute um Informationsbeschaffung und Datenanalyse im Zeitalter von Atomunglücken, weil wir werden zwar informiert, aber wir wissen eigentlich nicht so genau, was davon stimmt. Jonas ist gerade noch am Telefon und meint, was die Politiker sagen, ist eigentlich alles total widersprüchlich. Jonas, zum Schluss noch, was wäre denn deine bevorzugte Variante jetzt?
Meine bevorzugte Variante wäre, dass ich einfach die Möglichkeit habe informiert zu werden, darüber, was wir für Kapazitäten haben und darüber, was wir zurzeit für Kapazitäten nutzen und auf welchem Weg das geschieht, ob das durch eine Verstaatlichung oder einfach dadurch geschieht, dass diese privaten Unternehmen ihre Daten öffentlich machen müssen und publik machen müssen. Das liegt am Ende nicht in meiner Hand, aber ich denke, ich habe ein Recht darauf zu erfahren, was da eigentlich passiert, damit ich auch selbst ein Bild bilden kann.
Wenn es also so wichtig ist, weil es um unsere Energie geht und weil man da möglicherweise ein ganzes Land mit verstrahlt, dann wollen wir auch freien Zugriff. Ist quasi das, was du sagst.
Genau.
Alles klar. Dann vielen Dank und viel Spaß noch. Und jetzt kommt Thomas mit einem Argument, das auch gerne von Befürwortern gemacht wird. Der sagt nämlich, ja, also abschalten wird doch Quatsch, weil in Frankreich werden ja auch Atomkraftwerke gebaut. Thomas, wieso ist das ein Argument?
Ja, so ganz, ganz meine ich es nicht.
Ich bin natürlich gegen die Atomkraft.
Aber das Problem bei der ganzen Geschichte ist, Deutschland schaltet sieben AKWs ab.
Ich sag jetzt mal, macht jetzt ein bisschen auf Wahlkampf, sind wir uns ja irgendwo alle einig. Aber die Nachbarländer bauen auf. Polen fängt an zu bauen, Frankreich ist Atommacht Nummer eins, sage ich mal, in Sachen AKWs. Die machen ja, weiß ich nicht, ich glaube, ich hab nur Gerüchte, küchemäßig hat Frankreich die meisten. Genau. Und wollen aufstocken auf ungefähr 80.
Hab ich auch gehört.
Ob es bestimmt stimmt, weiß ich nicht.
Keine Ahnung. Ist in dem Moment keine Lösung. Ich sage mal, trifft es irgendwo in Europa ein Kraftwerk, sind wir halt alle dran.
Na genau, darum brauchen wir sowas wie die Nordseeleitung, dass wir eben den Strom da nicht erkaufen müssen. Richtig, richtig bin ich dafür.
Aber ich muss auch dazu sagen, ich komme aus dem Betonbau. Ich habe bei der EMS von EON eine Möbungsverbrennungsanlage aufgebaut mit dem Betonbau und die eigentlich hätte stehen sollen auf der deutschen Seite von der EMS, aber auf der holländischen Seite von der EMS, diesem Delta-Becken, weil ja, da oben sage ich mal und wie soll ich es erklären, ich will klingelnd zu nahe treten, aber Westdeutschland hat und ist da immer noch Westdeutschland wohl sagen muss, die sich da immer noch so gerne sträuben. Also Nordseeleitung von oben mit Windkraft, die ja hauptsächlich oben im Norden entsteht, runterzuziehen bis ins Ruhrgebiet stößt sowas auf heftige Kritik von den Einwohnern, die da oben wohnen, was für mich unvorstellbar ist.
Na gut, muss man sich mal am Riemen reißen und irgendwie mal zusammenhalten.
Richtig, man muss sich da am Riemen reißen, richtig. Also ich bin ja dafür auf jeden Fall.
Ich würde gerne noch mal zurückkommen zu der ursprünglichen Ansage, die du gemacht hast. Weil das erinnert mich doch sehr an Politik, also zu sagen, und wir, es nützt doch nichts, wenn wir abschalten. Aber das ist ja Quatsch. Also weil ich finde, gerade bei solchen Dingen, ist ja das eine total verquere Situation, zu sagen, wir machen nichts Gutes, weil andere machen es ja auch nicht.
Ja, richtig.
Nein, auf jeden Fall. Ich finde es ja gut. Ja, weil ich meine, Krümel ist von uns 90 Kilometer weg. Das ist ja der Störfer Nummer eins gewesen, jetzt hier in der Region, also zwischen Hamburg und Berlin.
Erst RAFO brandt das und so weiter und so fort. Ich bin 100 Prozent dafür, dass die Dinge abgeschalten werden, auf jeden Fall.
Also ich bin auch immer noch gebrannt, mag die Anführungsstrichen von Tschernobyl, ich kann mich daran erinnern, dass man vor adapterter Zeit mit einem Koffer rauf auf Hilfen kam, was sowas vorher nie gab. Aber ich bin auf jeden Fall dafür, dass die abgeschalten werden, auf jeden Fall runter fahren werden, der Anfang ist da. Aber es nützt ja nichts, wenn keiner da irgendwie mitzieht.
Kannst du dich noch erinnern, wo du zum ersten Mal von Fukushima gehört hast?
Ja, kann ich.
Nämlich?
Von Radio Fritz.
Hm, na ja auch.
Ich bin nicht schleim, nein, ich bin nicht schleim, das ist wirklich so.
Nein, es interessiert mich. Ich hab auch damals, ich bin jetzt 34, mit 15, 10, 7, 8 Jahren oder was, ich kann jetzt nicht mehr rechnen. Aber ich war mitgekriegt mit Tschernowieh und wir sitzen zwischen Hamburg und Berlin, wir hatten auch einen Anführungsflug in Westfernsehen, wir haben es mitgekriegt. Ja, die WWR hat ja eine große Glocke gehabt, da kam ja nichts rüber, angeblich. Aber es ist halt nun mal so, dass das so nicht geht. Und man kann ja heute noch gucken und heute schon Strahlung nachweisen. Auch hier in Deutschland hat von Tschernowieh passiert, das ist auch weit weg.
Da bin ich mal gespannt, wie das in Fukushima aussieht.
Und Fukushima ist mal ganz anders aus, würde ich mal sagen.
Also Fukushima ist, wenn das nicht hochgeht, wollen wir mal nicht hoffen, dass das alles so bleibt.
Darüber können wir gleich nochmal reden, über die partielle Kernschmeiße, die irgendwie angefangen hat. Thomas, dir auf jeden Fall schonmal vielen Dank. Und, ja, mal, würde ich dich noch gerne noch mal fragen, mit der partiell angefangenen Kernschmelze, ist das Neusprech oder gibt es sowas?
Ja doch, das ist schon Neusprech, man merkt es schon an der Formulierung. Die partiell angefangene Kernschmelze, da ist also zweimal relativiert, dass es eine Kernschmelze ist. Nun, kann man auch dazu sagen, weil hier im Chat auch kam ja, die Japaner seien so arrogant, die informieren nicht. Es ist natürlich auch bei den Japanern, die japanische Sprache, die gesprochene Sprache ist halt sehr auf Höflichkeit ausgelegt, da kann man sehr leicht Dinge auch unklar lassen. Man kann natürlich auch auf japanisch alles nochmal genau klären, aber wenn man natürlich daran kein Interesse hat, dann lässt man es also eben unklaren.
Du hast es im Vorbereitungssetum schon mal genau erklärt, woher das kommt, dass man im japanischen noch ungenauer sein kann als im deutschen. Das finde ich jetzt mal, glaube ich, für die Hörer auch spannend, woran das liegt.
Ja, das liegt daran, dass wenn man also mündlich spricht, das gilt vor allen Dingen für das Gesprochene, dann benutzt man halt besonders viele Höflichkeitsformen. Und bei den Höflichkeitsformen ist es so, dass es höfliche Formen für Bewegungsverben gibt und dann ist immer die Richtung des Bewegungsverbs nicht mehr klar. Also kommen und gehen ist dann das gleiche Verb. Und damit ist es halt nie so richtig klar, ob jetzt etwas erst in Gang kommt oder schon geht. Und das ist halt deshalb, also wenn man das dann so übersetzt, heißt es eben ja, es beginnt dort etwas. Aber es könnte auch sein, es geht voran.
Im Gegensatz zu der geschriebenen?
Genau. In der geschriebenen Sprache kann man das natürlich dann, also die ist dann verwendungsmäßig drastisch. Aber wenn halt der Regierungssprecher etwas erklärt hat, dann ist das in der Regel mündlich und dann muss man es halt interpretieren.
Das heißt, Interpretationssache und dann noch eine Übersetzungsprobleme möglicherweise. Das heißt, ihr geht jetzt von der Kernschmelze aus oder?
Ja, sicher. Also da ist mindestens in einem Fall eine Kernschmelze.
Vor allem, wenn sie sprechen von 1000 Millisievert pro Stunde.
Ja, ein Sievert, das ist erheblich.
Das ist ein Sievert und das ist erheblich. Also die tödliche Dosis, von der man immer so ausgeht, liegt im Bereich von zwei bis fünf. Und allein die Ausdrucksform 1000 Millisievert ist schon, also das liest man ein, zwei Mal, dann fasst man sich an den Kopf, sie wollen also nicht sagen, dass da irgendwie ein Sievert, sondern sie streuen dann noch dieses Milli ein, damit es trotz der 1000 noch ein bisschen weniger aussieht.
Naja, du musst auch denken, jetzt sind wir pro Zeit, also es sind 1000 Millisievert pro Stunde, also ein Sievert pro Stunde. Wenn ein Arbeiter da vier Stunden arbeitet, dann hat er halt die tödliche Dosis.
Genau, sie schicken sie da jetzt in so 15 Minuten Etappen rein und das ist halt eine statistische Angelegenheit, also kannst du auch nicht sagen, dass irgendjemand nach fünf Sievert definitiv und auf jeden Fall oder was auch immer, das ist halt eine statistische Sache und da überhaupt jemanden für 15 Minuten reinzuschicken, ja.
Ich hab da neulich einen schönen Spruch, auf Twitter hab ich das immer gelesen, ist eigentlich der beste Spruch, den ich nicht mal gehört habe, ist, wenn Statistiker dir sagt, dass ein Fluss durchschnittlich einen halben Meter tief ist, dann solltest du nicht durchgehen und ich glaube, das trifft das dann tatsächlich auch. Die ganzen Dinge, die da in Japan passieren, die wirken ja oft ein bisschen hilflos, weiter hergeholt, je nachdem, also irgendwie wir spannen jetzt planend über den Reaktor, wir werfen da mit Hubschraubern Wasser drüber. Ich frage mich aber, heute gab es auf Kryptom hochauflösende Fotos von diesem Reaktordingens. Da hat man das gesehen, an einem Gebäude sehr schön, da ist dieser riesige Reaktorblock, der quasi nur noch aus einem Skelett besteht, also dieses Gebäude, und da ist so ein kleiner Minilaster, der so einen kleinen Minischlauch da oben draufhält, und dann spritzt er so ein bisschen Wasser raus. Ist das eigentlich, sagen wir, also in Aktionismus gegossenes Neusprech? Also macht man das, weil man sich in der Sprache immer darauf bezieht, dass man jetzt noch was machen muss?
Also es gibt erstmal einen sprachlichen Aspekt, das wird dann von Krisenmanagement gesprochen. Aber natürlich ist das keine Krise, sondern eine Katastrophe. Also Krisenmanagement passt da natürlich nicht. Und dann ist aber klar, dass die Betreiberfirma und die Politiker natürlich zeigen wollen, wir tun was. Und dann wird eben irgendwas gemacht. Aber das hilft halt eigentlich nicht. Ich meine, das ist ja der Punkt, auch mit der Kernschmelze. Die Gerät, die beginnt, und dann ist sie nicht mehr zu stoppen. Denn es wird halt immer heißer und immer heißer. Und man müsste es halt plötzlich kühlen, kann es aber nicht kühlen. Also ist es nicht zu stoppen. Und ich meine, wenn das dann bei 2.000, 2.500 Grad angekommen ist, dann ist es mit dem Wasser, mit der Wasserkühlung nicht mehr.
Das Problem ist, dass es dann schon anfängt zu tropfen. Und genau das ist, was man irgendwie vermeiden wollte. Und das kann dann nicht ein bisschen anfangen. Das ist wie ein bisschen schwanger. Da ist dann halt die Situation erreicht, die man die ganze Zeit verhindern wollte.
So ist es einfach. Aber um das noch mal auf den Punkt zu bringen, stellt sich für mich dann so dar, weil die Politiker dieses Neusprech benutzen, von dem man Neusprech ist. Deswegen können sie quasi nicht zugeben, dass sie jetzt keinen Plan mehr haben. Und das hat dann tatsächlich reale Konsequenzen. Also in Deutschland ist es ja noch so, okay, das wird halt weiter betrieben. Glücklicherweise ist noch nichts passiert. Also uns ebensovorgehend auch nicht. Aber dort in Japan hat das halt die krassen Konsequenzen, dass dann Leute quasi verheizt werden.
Genau.
Aufgrund von Neusprech.
Na gut, das ist in Russland aber auch passiert.
Genau, das ist in Russland auch passiert. Aber weil du vorhin gesagt hast, die Politiker können nicht anders oder so. Man muss ja auch sehen, was hier im Vorhinein passiert. Es gibt ja keinen Katastrophenplan, der wirklich adäquat wäre, wo man wirklich vorher weiß, was man tun kann. Also das ist ein weiterer Grund, warum man die Kernkraftwerke nicht betreiben darf.
Das ist sozusagen ein auslegungsüberschreitender Störfall. Es ist quasi ein Störfall, der nicht vorgesehen ist und der überschreitet halt den Rahmen, für den das Ganze ausgelegt ist. Das ist das Neusprechwort für Gau.
Oder auch das mit dem Restrisiko, was du vorhin angesprochen hast. Das klingt wie so ein bisschen, naja, Restrisiko, Rest, ein kleiner Rest, ich sage es immer. Aber es ist, also erstmal ist ein Risiko immer ein Restrisiko, denn beim Risiko geht es immer um einen Rest. Und dann sieht man aber in diesem Fall, also normalerweise, also Risiko zeichnet sich dadurch aus, dass man sich dagegen versichern kann. Weil Risiko immer, da weiß man, also so und so viel, so ist das, da müssen die Prämien halt so sein. Aber hier handelt es sich um etwas, wo man sich nicht gegenversichern kann. Also keine Versicherung würde das Restrisiko der AKWs...
Also es ist in der Tat de facto so, dass es keine Versicherung gibt, die das tut.
Ja, und damit ist es ja ein Risiko.
Da habe ich ja neulich was anderes gelesen. Und zwar ist es so, dass Kernkraftwerke in Deutschland wohl mit 250 Millionen versichert sind, sozusagen bei der Versicherung. Und die müssen aber versichert sein über 2, 5 Milliarden. Was sie dann gemacht haben ist, sie haben sich gegenseitig versichert. Also die Betreiber der verschiedenen Kernkraftwerke haben sich gegenseitig die Garantie gegeben. Also wenn dir jetzt was passiert, dann springen wir mit ein.
Aber das ist nicht das Restrisiko, was versichert ist. Das sind die übrigen Risiken.
Aber das Schöne ist, man kann dann sagen, das Kernkraftwerk ist versichert. Das ist doch eigentlich alles Mutter, oder?
Du hast so ein Batzen Geld, mit dem man dann spekulieren kann.
Ja, was mich gefragt hat, ist, was passiert, wenn zwei gleichzeitig, dann sind das ja schon 5 Milliarden. Ach so, stimmt, wie konnte ich das vergessen? Ja, das ist unwahrscheinlich vorgesehen. Wir haben jetzt sozusagen, vor allem über die erste Erklärung von Frau Merkel gesprochen. Gibt es jetzt über die Wochen, also irgendwie Herr Röttgen sagt ja ja, aber vielleicht nicht und ich habe es ja schon immer gesagt, aber eigentlich darf ich das nicht und so. Hast du noch irgendwelche Stilblüten beobachtet, die man jetzt noch erwähnen könnte?
Naja, also ich habe es doch vorhin schon gesagt, es gibt halt immer etwas, was wiederkehrt. Das ist eben die Sache mit der Tagesordnung. Das finde ich also sehr auffällig, dass immer noch dieses Bild von der Tagesordnung verwendet wird. Also egal, wer spricht, wird immer gleich von der Tagesordnung gesprochen. Das ist sehr auffällig.
Das Thema ist also nicht auf der Tagesordnung?
Nein, nein, nein. Also es gibt irgendwie eine Tagesordnung, die wir nicht genau kennen, aber soll wohl sein, dass man weitermacht mit den Kernkraftwerken. Und jetzt soll halt im Moment mal eben nicht zur Tagesordnung übergegangen werden, im Oratorium oder was auch immer. Aber es ist halt tatsächlich diese Idee der Tagesordnung, dass es eine Ordnung gibt, ein Ablauf der Dinge, der eben, also dieser Ablauf ist eben alternativlos. Jetzt macht man eine kurze Pause und dann geht es weiter im Takt. Und das ist eben das, was ich da so störend finde. Weil es ganz klar ausdrückt, dass hier niemand gewillt ist, eine Politik zu verändern. Also was anderes zu machen. Sondern es soll nur mal kurz pausiert werden und dann geht die Ordnung der Dinge halt weiter.
Und die Ordnung der Dinge ist ja, dass wir Atomkraftwerke haben.
Genau. Und haben sollen.
Ja, natürlich. Das ist ja auch abgesehen von ungesehenen. Also das ist schön. Gerade siehst du hier neben bei NT-V, da steht, Lage, Fukushima, unverändert schlecht. Das ist genau das, was in den Medien gerade passiert, zu sagen, weil die Aktivität 4.350 fach überhöht.
Ja, was ist denn das normale, wohin geht es denn? Also das ist kein absoluter, das ist irgendwie, das ist eine Aussage, mit der man nichts anfangen kann.
Ja, weil du gerade sagtest, neue Wendungen, was auffällt. Zum Beispiel wird jetzt immer gesagt, in den nächsten Monaten. Also erstmal wird uns dieses Unglück in Japan Millionen von Monaten beschäftigen. Die Halbwertzeit von Cesium ist nämlich relativ hoch. Und da kann man schon mal von 10.000 Jahren sprechen. Also diese Monate. Und dann wird es mit den nächsten Monaten ja auch immer auf Deutschland bezogen. Aber wenn wir denken, das Moratorium hat ja schon begonnen. Das heißt, der erste Monat ist irgendwie halb rum. Also es sind ja jetzt nicht die nächsten Monate, sondern muss ja dann in anderthalb Monaten ist das Moratorium vorbei. Das heißt, man muss im nächsten Monat ja schon eine Entscheidung haben.
Ja, aber das bedeutet, wir deutschen wieder total vorne. Das bedeutet nämlich, unser Moratorium und die Stresstests sind schneller fertig, als sie die Katastrophe in Japan unter Kontrolle. Das ist doch großartig. Kommen wir noch mal zurück zu den Informationsquellen, aus denen man sich bedienen kann. Da hat Manu zu angerufen, die weiß ich gar nicht eine Frage dazu hat oder welche nennen will. Hallo Manu. Ach ja, wie man es macht, macht man es falsch. Willst du uns jetzt deine Informationsquellen präsentieren?
Ja, wenn ihr das möchtet, kann ich das auch tun. Ich habe relativ schnell festgestellt, dass das, was in den Mainstream-Medien läuft, erstens keinen Sinn ergibt, zweitens scheinbar auch fachlich nicht ganz korrekt war. Daraufhin habe ich angefangen im Netz natürlich nach Alternativen zu suchen, mich auch erst mal allgemein zu Störfall zu informieren, weil das war ja doch etwas, das man vorher nicht so richtig auf dem Zettel hatte. Und habe dann recht schnell festgestellt, dass es auch im Netz nicht ganz einfach ist, an verlässliche Quellen zu kommen. Habe dann aber festgestellt, dass eben doch Seiten, gerade aus japanischer Ebene, vorhanden sind, auf denen man zumindest auf handfeste Messwerte zurückgreifen muss, kann, was natürlich zur Folge hat, dass man sich mit der ganzen Materie doch etwas intensiver beschäftigen muss. Dabei habe ich festgestellt, dass es fantastische Blogs am Internet gibt, wo auch Leute, die sich mit der Materie deutlich beschäftigt haben, bzw. sich auch studieren, Informationen auf einer sehr einfachen Ebene zu verfügen stellen, so dass man auch als Laie in der Lage ist, sie doch relativ schnell zu verstehen und dahinter zu steigen, was die Messwerte zu bedeuten haben.
Jetzt muss ich kurz zu der Frage, du meinst Seiten aus Japan, hast du englischsprachige Seiten oder sprichst du japanisch?
Nein, englischsprachig. Japanisch gehört nicht zu meinen Repertoireseiten. Auf Deutsch gibt es meines Wissens nur eine, die die Informationen entsprechend auch für Laien aufbereitet. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich bei euch mit URLs durch die Gegend werfen soll darf.
Na ja, das wird jetzt glaube ich hier über das Radio zu weit führen. Du kannst aber gerne ins Wiki zur Sendung gehen oder der Chaosradio.de dort einfach reinwerfen. Dann können nämlich alle anderen auch klicken. Das wäre ganz praktisch.
Hervorragend, wäre ich nachher probieren. Wobei ich eine gerne loswerden würde, das wäre nämlich der Physikblock EU, weil eben das die Jungs sind, die doch in der Lage sind, auch der breiten Masse und dem breiten interessierten Bevölkerung eben die Informationen so zur Verfügung zu stellen, dass man sie auch versteht und vor allen Dingen hat sich dort eine Kultur entwickelt, die sehr technisch und doch verständlich über die Vorgänge diskutiert, wo man dann auch sehr schnell feststellen muss, dass selbst die Informationen, die man aus den Medien oder aus öffentlicher japanischer Seite bekommt, eben doch mangelhaft bis fehlerhaft sind oder eben nur die halbe Wahrheit darstellt.
Das finde ich aber ganz spannend von wegen der Informationsbeschaffung. An welchem Punkt machst du fest, dass Leute, die zwar vom Fach sind, aber hier in Deutschland sitzen, zuverlässigere Informationen haben als die von vor Ort?
Ich gehe aber nicht von zuverlässigeren Informationen aus, sondern einfach von der von der Interpretation der vorhandenen Misswerte, dass man dann schon sagen kann, also wenn wir feststellen, wir haben einen Reaktor irgendwie 400 Grad plus zweimal Druck, kann der nicht dicht sein, weil eben bei 400 Grad und ein bisschen Wasser eben deutlich höherer Druck existieren müsste. Das würde vermutlich dem normalen Nutzer nicht auffallen, aber eben Leute, die sich mit der Materie intensiv beschäftigen, stellen dann eben sowas auch ganz schnell fest und können dann daraus auch Rückschlüsse auf die Technik führen beziehungsweise in den Quellen, wo ich mich jetzt bewegt habe, war es elementar wichtig, dass die Leute eben Kenntnis von Reaktorsicherheit und auch von dem Aufbau von diversen Reaktoren hatten, so dass die Informationen, die zu bekommen waren, ganz anders deuten konnten, als sie in der Presse oder im Fernsehen publiziert wurden.
Würdest du sagen, die Massenmedien würdest du gar nicht mehr benutzen für solche Sachen?
Ich kann sogar sagen, ich verzichte seit zwei Wochen komplett auf Informationen aus den Massenmedien, weil ich mich dann in einer Regel darüber geärgert habe, dass dort entweder die halbe Wahrheit oder teilweise auch Messwerte deutlich verfeilscht dargestellt werden. Also wir haben den letzten Tagen da ganz deutlich beobachten können, dass Milli, Mycro und Mega irgendwie bunt durcheinander gewürfelt wurden, aber nichts mehr mit den Messwerten zu tun hatten, wenn man sie dann auch in den Massenmedien mal veröffentlicht hat. Das war teilweise schockierend.
Würdest du sagen, das finde ich immer eine spannende Frage, wenn es um diese Diskussion geht, weil die Massenmedien haben immer das Problem, sie dürfen die Informationen erst anbringen, wenn sie sie entweder selber verifiziert haben oder unter Angabe der Quelle. Würdest du es denn als adäquat empfinden, wenn Massenmedien anfangen zu sagen, wir haben mir dieses Blog gelesen, guckt euch das mal an, das klingt ganz gut, wir können natürlich auch nicht so genau verifizieren, ob das wahr ist.
Nein, ich will nicht, dass ich die Massenmedien auf den Blog beziehe, der war halt nur dadurch dazu gut, um mir die Messwerte, die ich halt von offizieller Stelle, zum Beispiel von einer japanischen Atom- und Industrieaufsicht.
Also du meinst, die Massenmedien sollen einfach mal ordentlich erarbeiten, weil sie so viel geschlammt haben?
Ja, nicht geschlammt.
Es geht dort einfach...
In den letzten Tagen hat man ganz deutlich gemerkt, dass sich jeder, der sich Experte auf die Fahnen geschrieben hat, sich zu dem Thema äußern durfte, hat man drei Experten gehört, hat man fünf verschiedene Meinungen. Und das führte teilweise meiner Meinung nach auch sehr zur Verunsicherung in der Bevölkerung. Also ich bin relativ später zugekommen, ich habe davon erst erfahren, als in den Massenmedien halt die Bilder von einer Explosion vom Block 1 liefen und war dann relativ geschockt, weil ich vorher davon ausgeknüpft bin, dass wir solche Bilder nach Tschernobyl nie wieder sehen werden, was sich ja nun als äußerst unwahr herausgestellt hat. Und habe dann unmittelbar versucht, verlässliche Informationen zu bekommen, habe festgestellt, dass halt auf den üblichen privaten Nachrichtensendern irgendwie eine Informationsveranstaltung im Stundenrhythmus läuft, die ja aufgrund der meinen Informationen logischerweise auch keine neuen Erkenntnisse bringen konnte. Und habe dann aber bei der Suche nach, wie komme ich schneller an Informationen, auch ganz schnell festgestellt, dass dort viele Angaben einfach falsch sind.
Wir machen jetzt mal Folgendes, wir nehmen es mal dem Matthias dazu, der hat nämlich eine technische Frage und vielleicht kannst du ihm ja mit einer Belesenheit über die ganzen Quellen weiterhelfen. Matthias, hallo. Tach?
Ja, hallo.
Du hast eine technische Frage.
Ja, und zwar, ich habe jetzt die Sendung gerade ein bisschen verfolgt und ich überlege schon lange, seit das jetzt war, mit dieser Katastrophe, weiß einer von euch, ob das irgendwie möglich ist, radioaktive Strahlung in irgendeiner Art und Weise sichtbar zu machen, also so, als wenn man zum Beispiel mit einer Infrarotbildkamera, ja, Darme-Strahlung sichtbar machen kann, ob das irgendwie möglich ist. Weil das gefährlich ist, finde ich, ist ja daran, dass das einfach nicht so unsichtbar ist. Man weiß eben nie, wo es ist. Man kann es nur messen mit einem Geigerzähler oder sich auf irgendwelche Werte verlassen, aber im Prinzip nicht irgendwie visualisieren, so gerade welche Strahlung.
Interessante Frage, habe ich ehrlich gesagt keinen Plan von, von euch jemand?
Aber Geigerzähler sind doch schon mal gar nicht so schlecht. Also ich finde, dieses Ticken ist schon sehr deutlich.
Naja, also… Ja, in einer Nebelkammer zum Beispiel kann man das nicht, weil das ist ja nicht so richtig viel, was da an, also aus so einer Lampe kommen jetzt wahrscheinlich mehr Vertun als Gamma-Strahler an. Also ich bin auch nicht Physiker, um das halt so zu sagen, aber bis auf eine Nebelkammer kann ich mir dort nicht groß was vorstellen.
Was macht eine Nebelkammer?
Das ist im Prinzip ein Gerät, wo man radioaktive Teilchen oder das, was da imitiert wurde, nachvollziehen kann. Da sieht man dann halt so eine Nebelspur und sieht auch, ob das jetzt, wenn da noch ein Feld zu angelegt ist, ein Gamma-Strahlung oder ein Alpha-Teilchen ist. Das ist ein Heliumkern, das ist ja relativ schwer und im Feld, einfach mal die ewikipedia.org/wiki/neokammer klicken.
Der Chat unter Chaosradio auf freenet.net sagt ja auch, dass man auch zum Beispiel auf Film, auf Fotofilm die Radioaktivität sehen kann.
Das sieht man an den Chernobyl Dokus.
Genau, das sieht man sehr schön. Der Punkt ist natürlich, wenn man das auf dem Film hat, ist es eigentlich schon zu spät. Diese Gamma-Strahlen sind halt sehr schnell und dann ist man schon erreicht worden von denen. Durch Sichtbarmachung oder auch durch Hörbarmachung, Geigerzähler, hat man immer nur so eine relativ späte Warnung davor.
Das funktioniert übrigens auch mit Digitalkameras ganz gut. Auch die CCD-Ships oder CMOS-Ships reagieren sehr wohl auf Gamma-Strahlung.
Wie äußert sich das dann? Durch massives Bildrauschen. Wenn die Kamera anfängt zu rauschen, dann sollte man vielleicht schneller das Weite suchen.
Im Moment sind ja alle Geigerzähler ausverkauft, aber sonst ist das schon eine gute Anschaffung. Ich habe mir mal einen ausgeliehen von einem Nerd. Im Chaos Computer Club laufen ja viele Leute mit solchen Equipment um.
Du meinst also, egal ob gerade irgendwo was explodiert ist oder nicht?
Ja, es ist immer ganz gut, so etwas zu haben. Ich habe also bei mir in der Wohnung schon mal alles ausgemessen. Allerdings vor dem Unlück. Aber ich fand das sehr interessant.
Eine Banane zu halten. Einer der lustigsten Wikipedia-Artikel, den ich mir in dem Zusammenhang durchgelesen habe, war die Banane-Equivalentdosis.
Okay, und was ist die Banane? Mann, Leute, lasst doch nicht alles aus der Nase ziehen. Was ist denn die Banane-Equivalentdosis?
Die beruht darauf, dass man in Tokio einen Stahlenwert festgestellt hat, der meines Wissens irgendwo bei 0, 01 sieben Mikrosievert pro Stunde lag. Und dann hat sich ein Atomphysiker hingesetzt und hat gesagt, lasst auf, Jungs, wenn wir uns eine Banane angucken, eine Banane enthält relativ viel Karium. Karium kommt in seiner natürlichen Form auch im Isotrop Karium-40 vor Karium-40 strahlt. Wenn man jetzt davon ausgeht, wir messen mal eine Banane aus, stellt man relativ schnell fest, dass wenn man jede Stunde eine Banane ist, hat man in etwa dieselbe Dosis aufgenommen, als hätte man sich in Tokio aufgehalten. Die Betreiber des Physik-Blocks weisen darauf hin, dass der Verzehr einer Banane mit Sicherheit gesundheitsschädlich ist, allerdings nicht auf die Strahlung zurückzuführen, sondern auf die einseitige Annäherung.
Okay, da wird also auch ein bisschen von der Panikmache runtergekommen. Das finde ich ja immer ganz schwierig, auch bei diesem ganzen Thema, dass man so schnell auf die, ich will nicht sagen die falsche Seite, aber diese Gradwanderung zwischen jetzt nicht Panik machen, aber trotzdem immer das Auge offen halten und sich nicht eindurlen lassen. Von sich aus Beschreibung ist wirklich sehr schwierig. Wie macht ihr das denn eigentlich? Fühlt ihr euch hier sicher, Man und Matthias?
Ja, also ich mich momentan schon eben, weil ich mich mit der Materie deutlich beschäftigt habe und der Fressen überzeugt bin, dass bei uns die Strahlung nicht so hoch werden wird, auch wenn der Wind dringendstig steht, als dass ich jetzt hier in akuter Gefahr wäre. Was unsere Regierung angeht, ob ich mich da sicher fühlen kann, was da an Informationen rausgeht, halte ich noch für fraglich.
Das ist eine andere Frage in der Tat. Matthias, wie sieht es bei dir aus?
Ja, also kann ich mich eigentlich auch nur so anschließen. Ich glaube jetzt auch nicht, dass die Strahlung direkt bis hierhin kommt. Allerdings, die indirekten Auswirkungen der Katastrophe können natürlich schon verheerender werden. Also wenn man auch überlegt, was das eventuell für Auswirkungen auf die Finanzmärkte, auf die Börsen etc. haben könnte. Weil ja Japan doch auch schon eine relativ große Volkswirtschaft ist. Das macht mir persönlich auch schon ein paar Sorgen, weil in der Geschichte einige Wirtschaftskrisen oder einige große Krisen passiert.
Was machen wir da jetzt weniger um die Finanzmärkte als auch um dieses Land? Einfache Sorgen, weil die hatten halt nicht nur diese AKW-Geschichte, sondern auch ein Erdbeben und ein Tsunami, wo irgendwie 100.000 Leute, 100.000 Leute obdachlos geworden sind. Und zum anderen ist Japan jetzt nicht so furchtbar groß. Also das Wetter in den nächsten Wochen und Monaten und weitere Strahlenemissionen oder Material, was da rauskommt, das kann da noch ganz schnell ganz, ganz böse werden, weil so viel Land ist, dass nicht was da verstrahlt werden kann und muss, damit man keinen Spaß mehr hat in dem Land. Also das hat schon durchaus das Potenzial, so ein Staat wie Japan deutlich, ich werde jetzt nicht sagen, von der Landkarte zu wischen, aber eine große Teile unbewohnbar zu machen.
Ja, und das hat natürlich wirklich auch ganz schwere Folgen. Einmal natürlich in Japan, da kann man sagen, ich bin so weit weg, aber ich meine, wir sind natürlich eine Welt. Und wenn da alles zusammenbricht und viele Menschen leiden, hat das natürlich auch dann weitere Auswirkungen.
Düstere Aussichten kann man sagen. Und dazu kommt noch, dass hier in Deutschland auch nicht so ganz klar ist, was mit unseren Atomkraftwerken wird. Wir werden gleich nochmal ein bisschen weiter in die Zukunft gucken. Jetzt haben wir gleich noch ein kleines Stückchen Musik, dann Fritz Info mit Nachrichten, Wetter und Verkehr. Und dann weiter mit der letzten halben Stunde Chaosradio.
So gleich.
Und eine halbe haben wir noch hier beim Chaosradio am letzten Donnerstag im Monat. Es geht heute um Informationsverwaltung, Beschaffung und Analyse im Zeitalter von Atomunglücken. Wir haben schon reichherzig darüber gesprochen, wie man als Nerd helfen kann mit dem Projekt Geigercrow zum Beispiel und was die Politiker und so erzählen und wie man da rumkommt und was man davon ernst nehmen kann und was nicht. Ihr seid auch in der letzten halben Stunde noch aufgerufen, anzurufen und dann 0331 70 97 110 und Maha und Nibbler sind hier zu Gast. Und Maha ist ja ein Neusprechexperte und wir können jetzt mal noch zum Schluss zu den ganz grundlegenden Dingen kommen, nämlich du beschäftigst dich auch mit einzelnen Worten, die mit dem Thema zu tun haben und es gibt das schöne mich an einem Müsli Riegel erinnernden frischen vor Kraft trotz den Begriff Kernkraft.
Das wollen wir auch noch in unserem Neusprechblog, also neusprech.org, auseinandernehmen. Das Problem ist halt nur, dass wir dazu recherchieren müssen in Zeiten, wo das alles im Internet noch nicht so richtig dokumentiert ist. Und das ist immer so anstrengend. Also wenn jemand was weiß, bitte gebt uns die Information. Also es fällt halt auf, dass man in älteren Texten Atomenergie findet, dann Atomkraft und plötzlich Kernkraft. Und wenn man jetzt tatsächlich, der eine oder andere erinnert sich noch, da gab es diese Kampagne CO2, also gegen CO2, und auf den Plakaten der Energiebetreiber stand dann auch immer Kernkraft und nicht Atomkraft. Also Atomkraft war schon negativ besetzt, weil man das kannte vom Aufkleber Atomkraft, nein danke, dann wurde Kernkraft besagt. Und eben ganz früher eben Atomenergie. Also von der Atomenergie ist man zu Atomkraft gekommen, Kraft klingt sehr positiv, und dann Kernkraft statt Atomkraft. Aber eigentlich passt Kernkraft gar nicht, denn bei der Kernkraft, mit der Kernkraft, sagen wir eigentlich die Kräfte, die im Kern den Kern zusammenhalten. Und ja, was man hier gewinnt, ist ja Energie, die entsteht beim Zerfall des Kerns. Also es passt nicht so ganz von der Beschreibung. Jetzt tickt hier der Geigerzimmer.
Sind wir schon verstrahlt, oder?
Aha, gut, also man sieht, ein Wort ist irgendwann unangenehm geworden wegen Atomkraft und Erdanke, also wird was anderes gesagt, was noch schöner klingt. Kernkraft erinnert auch gar nicht mehr an Atom. Ähnlich auch im Englischen, da wird dann von Nuclear gesprochen. Nuclear ist eben auch nicht Atomic oder so. Nach der Atomic Bomb kommt dann eben der Nuclear Power.
Jetzt ist ja davon auszugehen, dass auch der Begriff Kernkraft dann sozusagen irgendwann auf diesen Aufklärung auftaucht, wo ein Danken nach dazu drauf steht. Vielleicht können wir jetzt gleich noch mal ein neues Wort entwickeln, ein positives Wort für diese Energien.
Ein positives Wort nach der Kernkraft.
Dein Tipp als Linguist, was kommt?
Man sieht es schon. Man sieht im Deutschen plötzlich das Adjektiv Nuklear. Das war nicht gebräuchlich in dem Zusammenhang.
Nuklearenergie.
Nuklearenergie, genau.
Eine Renaissance des Energieworts und dann mit Nuklear davor.
Nuklear, genau.
So ein bisschen wissenschaftlich quasi.
Das ist die Malenwörter von Kern, vom Atomkern.
Aber Kernkraft klingt so ein bisschen nach Bio. Was ist denn so? Dinkelkern. Kernkraft, super. Wir haben jetzt die ganze Zeit auch schon darüber gesprochen, was denn eigentlich zuverlässige Informationsquellen sind heutzutage. Also einerseits um an die Daten zu kommen, was ist in Japan eigentlich wirklich los, was nicht wirklich einfach ist. Und andererseits auch um mal rauszufinden, was in Deutschland so abgeht. Was ist denn eure Empfehlung da? Also wir haben jetzt die Hörer angerufen und gesagt, so Twitter hat sie überraschenderweise, also für die Hörer überraschenderweise, sind an manchen Stellen auch gut informiert. Und es gibt einen Blog zum Beispiel, wurde gesagt, wo man die Hintergründe gut verstehen konnte. Und was zeichnet denn für euch jetzt heute in diesem Bereich eine zuverlässige Informationsquelle aus? Und wo findet man die?
Naja, also ich glaube, ich glaube, dass mit Twitter das gar nicht so schlecht ist. Denn bei Twitter wird eben doch, man hört immer von Journalisten, ja, aber das ist da alles, muss erst nachgeprüft werden und so.
Entschuldigung, ich möchte nicht über einen Kamm geschoren werden.
Ja, wir erinnern uns da an dieses Gespräch mit dem Regierungssprecher, wo der Regierungssprecher den Journalisten erzählt, was Twitter ist und die sagen immer, ja, aber das ist doch nicht sicher und naja, das geht doch nicht. Ja, aber das Interessante bei Twitter ist schon, dass die Information dann interessant wird, wenn die richtigen Leute, denen man eben folgt, von denen man Meinung an was hält, das dann eben auch retweeten. Und einer kann sich immer mal ehren, aber wenn dann das doch viele tun, ja, dann kann ich schon dem Ganzen vielleicht vertrauen, was da kommt.
Das ist in der Tat so die kleine Variante von dem, was ich auch empfehlen würde, sich einfach nicht nur aus Rennerquelle zu informieren, sondern aus verschiedenen Quellen und sich dann zu den Quellen auch immer angucken, wie ist die Motivation. Gerade was Blockbeiträge zu dem Thema angeht, findet man da durchaus Gehaltvolle, wo man irgendwie das Gefühl hat, von Physikern oder von fachlicher Stelle informiert zu werden. Aber die sind alle auch in einer gewissen Art und Weise gefärbt. Also es gibt Physiker, die sagen, ich erkläre das mit der Nuklearenergie. Das ist ganz sicher und ganz hm, deswegen und deswegen. Und gerade bei so einem Thema, wo es eben unterschiedliche Meinungen darüber geht, ist das halt alles immer so ein bisschen gefärbt. Also da ist wirklich die Vielfalt, sich aus mehreren Quellen zu informieren und sich zu gucken, wer hat das geschrieben, welches Interesse könnte er da haben und dann eben sich seine eigene Meinung daraus zu bilden.
Das ist natürlich richtig. Auf jeden Fall sollte man sich aus verschiedenen Quellen informieren, denn es ist einfach so, es gibt nicht die eine richtige Wahrheit. Es gibt immer viele Wahrheiten und von daher muss man eben auch tatsächlich mehrere Quellen sich anschauen. Also ich glaube, das ist wirklich ganz, ganz wichtig. Natürlich ist es so, dass man sicherlich auch, ja, sich Hintergrundwissen beschaffen kann. Das ist ja inzwischen auch ganz leicht, da kann man in die Wikipedia schauen, die wir zwar auch manchmal schlecht geredet, aber immerhin. Also das ist ein Zugang, da gibt es dann weitere Links und was da da so an Links ist, kann man sich ja dann anschauen und dann kommt man sehr schnell schon zu tiefen Einsichten.
Ich, also da werde ja das Gefühl nicht los, dass ihr, also auch häufiger hier in der Sendung sagt, dass man selber also aktiv werden muss.
Ja, man muss immer selber aktiv werden, auch wenn man Informationen haben will. Also das ist ja eben gerade der Ansatz, man darf sich nicht einfach bescheiden lassen von, es wurde ja vorhin schon gesagt, von den Massenmedien, man muss eben sich die Information holen. Das kann man natürlich auch auf den Webseiten der Tagesschau und so weiter, ist auch klar, ZDF, Mediathek und Arte, Dokus und sonst was. Aber man muss eben selber gucken und eben genauer hingucken und sich eben die Information holen. Ich glaube, das ist genau das, was man machen muss. Man muss selber aktiv werden und sich was holen und nicht einfach sich berieseln lassen.
Da würde ich jetzt aber gerne zum Schluss tatsächlich, also jetzt auf diesen Fall hier sozusagen bezogen mal gerne wissen, wo ihr euch sozusagen hauptsächlich informiert habt. Ich würde mal einen Anfang machen. Ich habe irgendwann gefunden eine deutsche Seite, die für mich ziemlich gut funktioniert hat. Das sind die Anti-Atom-Piraten. Die sind natürlich also politisch klar gefärbt. Die haben es aber wirklich sehr gut drauf gehabt, eine Mischung aus Informationen von Medien zu übernehmen. Die haben die Nachrichtenticker von Reuters im Auge gehabt und auch sozusagen so kleine Sachen von von nebenher zu sagen. Und die haben immer auch die Informationen, die unbestätigt waren, haben sich dann meistens als sozusagen wahr oder zumindest in der Richtung richtig herausgestellt. Das fand ich sehr gut. Dann fand ich sehr gut die Nachrichtangentur Reuters hat einen Feed, das fand ich ganz großartig, weil das das erste Mal gesehen habe bei einem großen Medium. Die haben also einen Feed, wo sie ihre eigenen Meldungen raus tun zu dem Thema, zu Fukushima, ein Live-Feed, der sich auch automatisch aktualisiert. Und die kennzeichnen ihre eigenen Meldungen. Die nehmen aber tatsächlich nach einer Prüfung auch User-Kommentare auf. Das heißt, da findet man natürlich nicht alles, aber das ist sozusagen eine sehr breite Masse und von einem Dienst, der auch sozusagen, also wo man weiß, der ist darauf angewiesen, dass er jetzt nicht irgendwie den größten Scheiß produziert. Und für Hintergrundberichte habe ich immer gerne den Guardian gelesen, die sind immer sehr gut. Da muss man natürlich Englisch können, also es gilt bei Reuters auch, aber das sind so für mich die drei Quellen eigentlich gewesen in den letzten Wochen, wo ich mich am besten informiert gefühlt habe.
Würde ich dir zustimmen. Ich würde auf jeden Fall aber noch ergänzen, Zeit Online. Zeit Online hat gerade am Anfang der Katastrophe, haben die ja nachts durchgemacht und waren der einzige deutschsprachige Ticker, natürlich dann Twitter, also Twicker kann man das so gleich nennen. Und da wurde wirklich also kontinuierlich informiert und auch auf, also mit wirklich guten Links. Also das hat mich auch sehr überzeugt. Ich hab dann ja sogar getwittert, dass offenbar Zeit Online jetzt das Nachrichtenmonopol in Deutschland übernommen hat. Von der Tagesschau kam nichts mehr, es war halb vier Uhr morgens, da haben die da andere Dinge zu tun gehabt, ich weiß nicht was. Aber bei Zeit Online ging es halt durch und das hat mich schon sehr überzeugt.
Ja, Zeit Online hat jetzt auch das Weblog Netzpolitik, also die ab morgen so eine Testphase übernommen. Übernommen, ja.
Zeitgleich zum neuen Design. Dazu aber vielleicht später mehr, was hast du denn, wo hast du dich denn informiert?
In der Tat auch diesen, das ist immer so das Problem, man hätte gerne halt sowas wie einen Feed, in dem man informiert wird über das, was passiert, da war in der Tat Reuters mit am, teilweise auch flottesten. Dann guckt man halt, man sucht dann auch nach einzelnen Begriffen, also man liest dann irgendwelche Sachverhalte und da muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen, kann ich mich nicht mehr an die einzelnen Seiten erinnern, aber das ging dann halt wirklich in die Tiefe, dass man sich anguckt, okay, der und der Sachverhalt, das lese ich jetzt da zwar, aber wie ist denn das wirklich? Dann verliert man sich auf den Seiten über die technischen Themen, den technischen Hintergrund von sowas.
Gibt es denn sowas sozusagen noch über die Wikipedia hinaus? Ich weiß, es ist schwierig, das jetzt kurz und knapp zu sagen und auch festzulegen, aber so ein Leitfaden für, wie unterscheide ich denn eigentlich eine Seite, eine Seite, die jetzt Informationen bietet, denen ich zumindest zum Teil trauen kann, von einer, die nur Blödsinn schreibt. Also was sind da eure Kriterien? Mal jetzt von Viagra-Werbung abgesehen.
Gegenverifizieren. Wenn da Dinge berichtet werden, werden die Berichte von anderer Seite, die nicht auch von dieser Quelle abgeschrieben haben, gestützt. Dann, welches Interesse besteht, also wer betreibt diese Informationsquelle und hat der eventuell oder die Interesse daran, die Information gefärbt darzustellen und ganz einfach eine Pausibilitätsprüfung und eben nach dem Motiv fragen.
Wir sind schon wieder bei selber nachdenken.
Na ja, also wenn man nicht so viel selber nachdenken will, kann man auch, das ist zwar immer gefährlich, aber kann man auch immer gucken, wer verlinkt denn noch auf die Seite. Das ist schon sehr aufschlussreich und da kann man sehr schnell wissen, also da kriegt man sehr schnell eine grobe Ahnung dafür, ob das seriös oder nicht seriös ist.
Jetzt würde ich zum, also fast zum Schluss, der ganze ist noch nicht, will noch zu einer kleinen Anekdote kommen, die ich sehr witzig fand. In Nibbler, du hast ja erzählt, dass du während deiner Arbeit für Geigercloud auch mit dem Hacker Space in Tokio Kontakt hattest.
Ja, die haben, das war auch so die Zielgruppe, die ich im Hinterkopf hatte, als ich mir überlegt habe, ja, den Crowd-Teil. Japan ist ein unglaublich technologieverliebtes Land, um da mal so ein Vorurteil zu transportieren. Und es muss da einfach Leute geben, die selbst an so Geräten bauen oder mit so Geräten Spaß haben, die eben sich mit dieser Radioaktivität in der einen oder anderen Form messtechnisch auseinandersetzen. Und der Hacker Space in Japan, die haben relativ früh schon daran gearbeitet, zum einen für die Leute, die davon betroffen sind, von dem Erdbeben und der Wohnungsproblematik, dass sie halt irgendwie jetzt kein Dach mehr über den Kopf haben, die haben Solarlampen gebaut, also Lampen, die sich tagsüber über Solarenergie aufladen und dann nachts eben über LEDs Licht abgeben. Wir haben da eine nach der anderen gelötet und verteilt und zum anderen auch einen Geigerzeller Bau-Workshop. Da waren sie auch noch nicht die einzigen im Internet, also es gibt eine ganze Handvoll Leute, die eben mit Mikrocontrollern selbst Mess-Equipment gebaut haben. Wir haben auch im CCCB jemanden, der Dexter hat da gebastelt, da habe ich den Link später. Ja, also das war ein relativ spannender Kontakt, weil die halt wirklich gesagt haben, ja, wir bauen da welche und werden das auch in Tokio verteilen. Also Tokio wird wahrscheinlich mit Abstand die engste Sensordichte haben, weil da eben eine ganze Handvoll Nerds sitzen, die, ich würde jetzt nicht sagen Spaß dran haben, aber die, ja, also die könnte man selbst bauen.
Das, wo ich tatsächlich ein bisschen lächeln musste, ist als so die Prioritätenliste irgendwie, also die man irgendwie schickt uns. Wie war das nochmal, die Top 3?
Wir arbeiten an Doppelpunkt Lampen, mobilen Handyladegeräten und Essensaufwärmungsapparaten. Also die Reihenfolge Licht, Kommunikationsinfrastruktur, Essen fand ich großartig.
Jetzt haben wir viel darüber geredet, was war und wie man damit klarkommen kann. Was sind denn eure Aussichten für, was wird jetzt passieren? Also würde mich ja quasi vor allem hier in Deutschland interessieren. Also wenn man dir so zuhört, denkt man ja so, okay, also eigentlich pasen die Politiker jetzt nur und es wird sich nichts ändern, also genau gar nichts. Ich habe ja tatsächlich manchmal noch die Hoffnung, vielleicht rocken wir ja doch irgendwie was.
Ja, ich glaube schon, dass das passieren kann, nur das wird dann eben passieren, so wie es eigentlich abzusehen ist, dass eben der, es wird ja immer von dem Konsens gesprochen, gerade der Röttgen hat jetzt von dem Konsens gesprochen, Konsens, also alle müssen wieder zu einem Konsens kommen bei Atomkraft und das wird halt sehr schwierig sein. Also ich glaube, es wird tatsächlich dann nochmal richtig Auseinandersetzungen geben mit großen Demonstrationen und so weiter und ich hoffe, dass auf diese Weise dann genug Druck aufgebaut wird, sodass es eben nicht so weitergehen kann. Richtig, das wird zu zeigen, dass die Tagesordnung mal endgültig abgesetzt wird.
Ja, dass das Teil der Tagesordnung wird, dass man sich damit auseinandersetzen muss, wie man das Problem eben löst.
Aber glaubt ihr wirklich, dass da in Deutschland Interesse dran besteht, ernsthaftes?
Seitens der Bevölkerung auf jeden Fall, wenn man sich die Demo angeschaut hat.
Doch, ich glaube auch. Also ich glaube, nach Tjernobyl ist es schon fast ungekippt. Und ja, da war die Welt aber noch anders. Da gab es halt noch den Ost-West-Konflikt in allen seinen Vorhangen und was weiß ich. Und dann waren die anderen immer die Schlechten, kann bei uns nicht passieren. Und so denke das ist jetzt anders. Und ich denke, es wird jetzt wirklich doch sehr viel stärker eben ein Widerspruch kommen. Aus der Bevölkerung kein Konsens.
Je nachdem, was man davon hält, bleibt zu hoffen, möchte ich an dieser Stelle sagen. So, so viel zur Atomkraft. Ich würde jetzt noch ein kurzes Stück Musik machen, dann reden wir noch mal. Genau, ich wollte gerade dazu kommen. Ich würde sagen, wir schließen jetzt das Thema ab, Atomkraft, machen ein kurzes Stück Musik, machen dann Werbung. Und danach geht es hier mit den Dingen weiter, die sonst noch so passieren. Wir sind gleich wieder da. Das ist auch Creative Commons Musik, sowas gibt es auch im Chaosradio. Bleiben uns nur noch wenige Minuten. Wir kommen jetzt zum Teil der Werbung. Als erstes muss da natürlich gesagt werden. Chaosradio gibt es auch als Podcast, natürlich auf Fritzsee, natürlich aber auch auf chaosradio.de gibt es auch einen Blog. Da könnt ihr noch mal kommentieren, wenn ihr irgendwie Anmerkungen noch habt zur Sendung, wenn ihr andere Dinge wollt oder genauso haben wollt oder wie auch immer. Sagt es uns dort, weil wenn ihr nichts sagt, dürft ihr nicht beschweren. So einfach ist das nämlich. Außerdem gibt es noch Veranstaltungshinweise.
Genau, also jetzt am Freitag um 18 Uhr in Bielefeld, ja wirklich in Bielefeld, Komm an! finden die Verleihung der Big Brother Awards statt. In der, wie heißt das da? Na ist auch egal. Also in diesem, wo das immer stattfindet. Und ja, da sind natürlich alle willkommen, vor allen Dingen, wer aus der Nähe von Bielefeld ist und auch weiter anreisen will. Ja, in der Ravensberger Spinnerei, gut. Also da lag ich gar nicht so schlecht bei den Spinnereien.
Weiß man eigentlich schon so? Irgendwie hat man schon so Gerüchte gehört, wer hier irgendwie erfolgreicher Kandidat möglicherweise ist.
Ja, es ist wohl auch diesmal, also man darf ja nichts verraten, es ist wohl auch diesmal ein Preisträger, also ein Preisträger, ein Vertreter eines großen Konzerns wird kommen. Oh! Wahrscheinlich hatten die sich nicht richtig in Form von jetzt aus. Das dürfte also spannend werden und wir werden auch ein bisschen über Neusprechen dort.
Wirst du auch da sein?
Ich werde auch da sein.
Ah, sehr schön.
Ja, direkt von hier nach Bielefeld. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich das finden werde.
Ja, hoffentlich kommst du wieder zurück.
Ja, das ist der Paralleluniversum. Da gibts glaube ich ein Wurmloch.
Das ist also auch einer von ihnen.
Ja, im Sommer gibt es auch noch was.
Genau, Chaos Communication Camp 2011 in Finofort bei Berlin. Das ist so ein alter Flugplatz. Das ist total kuschelig da. Fünf Tage mit den Hackern auf dem Feld. Gibt Internet, habe ich gehört. Da ist die Faser schon klar gemacht worden.
Ab Tag eins oder?
Bestimmt.
Okay, wenn es losgeht, geht es durch den Wald.
Also, wird auf jeden Fall hübsch werden, vom 10. bis zum 14. August.
Und was passiert da, außer, dass da gezeltet und gewählernd wird?
Da wird gezeltet, gewählernd, ausgetauscht und es gibt Vorträge. Wenn man sich die angucken möchte, kann man sich natürlich auch gestreamt angucken, aber hinkommen ist immer schick. Ich meine, wann kann man schon mal mit einer vierstelligen Anzahl von Hackern auf einem ehemaligen sowjetischen Flugplatz zählen mit Gigabit-Internet am Nordbock?
Und es ist wohl so, dass es da keinen Platzbruch gibt?
Nein, es gibt keinen Platzproblem. Im Gegensatz zum Kongress im Winter. Also von daher sollte man davon Gebrauch machen. Außerdem ist das einfach schön unter freiem Himmel, bei lauschiger Nacht mit absolut außergewöhnlicher Beleuchtung. Es wird da wirklich ganz tolle Beleuchtung geben. Da einfach dann abzuhängen und zu diskutieren und Party zu machen. Das ist einfach mal ganz, ganz toll. Also wer das verpasst, ist selber schuld.
Und das alles im kleinen Maßstab gibt es ja, wie ich immer wieder von euch höre. Jeden Donnerstag kann man im Club vorbeikommen. Von wann bis wann ist das nochmal?
Von 17 Uhr bis Mitternacht glaube ich.
Genau, aber bitte da das Zelt zu Hause lassen.
Da steht schon so viel rum in dem Club.
Aber kennenlernen kann man euch da. So, dann also viel Spaß mit dem Chaos Computer Club im Podcast, wenn ihr gerne mögt. Demnächst dann hier geht es gleich weiter mit Flo Heiler im Night Flight. Wir verabschieden uns, Nibbler, Maha, vielen Dank fürs Vorbeikommen. Und ja, ihr kennt den Abschluss. Jetzt gibt es eigentlich nur noch eins zu sagen.